Boom.
And we're alive and well,
I,
yeah,
a little closer.
A little closer.
Right about there.
All right.
How are you fell?
It's fantastic.
And how you doing?
Very nice to meet you.
Nice to meet you too.
You were remarkably normal.
Oh,
thanks.
I know that people were struck at how
normal I am.
I'm like,
this is like wow.
Really?
I think my roommate through the maze,
I guess sang a famous child.
Yeah.
That's a very unusual mays.
Uh,
yeah.
my life is unique to me.
That's what I like to say,
you know?
Yeah.
And I'm almost like a pure list person.
Like to a certain extent.
There's not too many people I can look
left and right.
And we,
you know,
I,
we have similar experiences.
Yeah.
Is there anybody that you ever contacted
like Jodie foster or someone who's made
it through and seems pretty put
together?
Not really,
no,
not really.
I mean,
it's kind of a weird cold call.
You know what I'm going to say?
Hey jodie foster,
I such a small clan of people,
like if a comic called me that I knew,
you know,
and they wanted to talk to me,
I would talk to them.
Cause it's such a small collection of
people.
I mean we do have our weekly therapy
sessions.
Yeah.
You know,
yeah.
Me,
Elijah Wood,
you know,
Jodie Foster,
you know.
Yeah.
Like we all get together and yeah,
we,
we weep.
You know,
it's actually,
we do primal screaming.
That's what we do.
I was describing when it was like,
I have a friend who,
uh,
Ricky Schroeder who,
is,
um,
you know,
obviously it was very famous when he was
young as well.
And one of my favorite theme songs,
TV theme songs of all times for spoons.
And I was saying that the way you
developed is not like the way the recipe
calls,
like the recipe calls for you to have a
childhood and try to figure out life and
then become a man and try to find
yourself and then try to find your path.
And by the time you be,
he became a man.
He was already famous.
And the same thing with you.
You were already famous as you were
developing and learning.
Yeah.
You know?
I don't know exactly how to like kind of
even describe it because it's always the
way my life has been kind of thing.
Like in the same way that like a lot of
kids like,
you know,
they'd go out and they catch bugs and
play sandlot baseball or whatever.
Like yeah.
He just like,
yeah.
Like that's the way it is.
Like you don't really realize how unique
the whole situation is until you have
perspective cause you have nothing to
compare it to really other than I guess
tv shows and movies and things like
that.
So I knew that my upbringing was unique,
you know,
I knew it knew it was different,
but at the same time it's kind of just,
it's not until you get some perspective,
some life experience,
but until you really realize that,
oh wait,
this was,
this was particularly weird.
You know?
I think one of the aspects is
particularly weird about it is a lot of
kids that grow up famous,
they grow up on the set.
Yeah.
And they grow up constantly around
people treat them very differently than
everyone else.
It's not just that you're famous,
it's that you're famous and you're also
the complete center attention.
Like you're the reason why we're here.
We're here to do this television show,
we're here to do this movie,
we're here to do this thing.
You're the star.
And that,
I think for a kid,
that's a very strange place to be.
Yeah.
And especially like,
I mean,
I like when I was a kid,
like me,
even before I started working,
I always liked being like the center of
attention kind of thing.
I was definitely,
I was just,
I was very boisterous,
you know.
But,
um,
but in general,
like I'd never really liked being fussed
over.
Like,
I didn't like,
you know,
like get the hair and makeup costume
people like poking at you all the time
and things like that.
That actually wasn't a huge fan after a
while of kind of like being that center
of attention.
It,
you know,
it,
it does become a job after a while.
I'm going to,
yeah,
like early on you kind of just do what
you do.
Look,
that's like I was good at it and boom it
in the same way.
Like they do like anything that you're
like you like it's where the child labor
laws don't apply to acting.
Yeah,
they do do that.
Yeah.
I'm,
I'm pretty well versed in child labor
laws.
Well,
it,
how's that work then?
Uh,
it goes from state to state.
Um,
they can work you like,
let's say look in New York,
they can work you 10 hours.
Yeah.
But it stopped right there.
They can work you like you can't get a
job if that's what you're,
that's what you're kind of like,
that's what their limit is.
At the same time you have to get three
hours of schooling in plus an hour of
lunch.
So really you're only,
you're available window is only six
hours or something like that a day.
And then like that also in like in that
six hours,
they're always like setting up the
lights for the next shot and you know,
hurry up and wait kind of part of you
know,
of things.
That's why I like the second home alone.
It took like nearly five months to film
because they can only,
I'm in virtually every scene and they
can only use me x amount of hours per
day kind of thing.
But isn't that the only job that you can
work when you're eight years old?
I don't know.
I,
I you can't be a carpenter.
I mean I guess you can do modeling,
you know,
I mean,
but again,
but like some kind of performing arts
kind of thing,
like there are dancers and so forth.
Um,
cause I was a,
uh,
I was a ballet dancer before I was an
actor.
Like yeah,
I did ballet for a number of years.
I'm a classically trained ballerina
right here.
That Ballerina,
if you're a man,
I,
I call it,
I say I'm a ballet dancer.
Um,
but there is a weird Bella Reno Oh look
at some of them use and I'm like,
I'm not,
I don't think I can call myself a
ballerina.
Like I just can't.
It's too bro.
Like it's from welcome back Kotter.
Exactly.
Babbo Reno Fellow Reno.
So I did that for a number of years and
there's a bunch of kids that do that and
you get paid and you do the work.
Wow.
So you know,
there are other,
I guess trades like business though,
right?
Yeah,
yeah.
That's what I mean.
I think it's more than the performing
arts kind of thing.
Like you don't,
you don't see a lot of kids work in the
coal mines anymore.
Like that kind of thing.
Yeah.
For good reason.
Right.
But some people think that that my six
year old dying of black lung,
you know,
there's some horrible pictures from like
the early 19 hundreds of people actually
working in the coal mines when they were
little tiny kids.
Yup.
Yeah.
I mean there are no newsies anymore,
you know,
like,
yeah.
Did you have any say in whether or not
you worked when you were young?
Uh,
not really.
No.
Look,
it was after a while it became,
like I said,
a job and it was,
I like,
I never chose the projects.
They were like,
my parents took,
you know,
essentially like chose them for me.
So there was kind of feel news Mccauley.
Yeah,
exactly.
Yep.
Yeah.
They called in the class.
Yeah,
there you go.
Good on.
And like I never read any of the
scripts.
Like I would,
I would just read the lines for like the
next day or whatever.
Like I would like get the gist of what
the movie was about,
but then I just kind of show up and hit
my marks,
find my light,
you know,
a,
and,
and recite my lines.
Oh,
so real.
It's kind of just like,
again,
it's what you do.
Like,
it's like in the same way that like,
like kids go to like school or something
like that.
Like,
you know,
you,
you fall into a routine to a certain
extent,
you know?
Well,
that's the thing about the human mind,
right?
So flexible you could adopt to any sort
of weird scenario and especially when
you're a kid,
I mean you can just bounce,
look on with time adapt so easily.
Exactly,
exactly.
And I always had like a good memory and
things like that.
Like I know I liked,
you know,
I was,
I was big and charismatic and I like had
a good memory like so I could remember
my lines.
Like that's pretty much what like if
you,
you know,
like not going to give any advice to any
people about like yeah,
you should put your kid into this line
of work.
But at the same time like what producers
really care about is whether or not you
remember your lines,
but they like people to get to never
work with kids or animals kind of thing.
And again,
they really,
all they really care about.
As you remember your lines really liked
because I apparently that's a problem.
Like for me it never was like if I ever
lost my place,
I would just see the script in my head
and just read it.
Like,
I kind of had a photographic memory back
then.
Oh,
it's faded now I'm 37.
I'm about to be 38 in two weeks.
It feels weird,
doesn't it?
Yeah.
You know?
Look up my,
my bowels are different.
Like
what's different about your bowel?
Oh yeah.
No,
just like,
uh,
I like she,
I just got,
uh,
doing some like random checkup kind of
thing and they're like,
oh,
we should scope you.
You know?
So they also,
you know,
they,
I did the,
the scoping like,
you know,
in my stomach kind of thing,
but they also,
uh,
you know,
I got a colonoscopy so I was actually
hoping like he's there,
put me under,
so I was like,
it didn't really matter to me,
but I was to put you under for a
colonoscopy.
Yeah,
yeah.
You know,
at least I had that and a scoping.
So I think,
I don't know,
again,
it's down the throat.
I was hoping,
I was actually hoping they were going
to,
uh,
use the butland first and then put it in
my mouth and just asked to mouth boom.
But no,
nothing.
Apparently they use different cameras.
Alright.
Probably designed different,
you don't go as deep.
Right.
But um,
cause they were like all worried I might
have an ulcer.
Oh.
Uh,
and so the good good stomach pains or
something kind of,
it's been a little iffy.
And uh,
so the good news,
I don't an ulcer bad news is I have two
ulcers.
So yeah.
So I'm dealing with that.
I've had to like curtail my lifestyle in
general.
Like I'm eating less red meat,
you know,
less carbonated beverages like
Ibuprofen,
no more Ibuprofen.
Like the honest stove.
It's terrible for your gut.
Yeah,
exactly.
So like I've had to like,
you know,
I used to like eat like burgers every
single day and now it's like I can have
two servings of red meat a week kind of
thing.
And it wasn't too hard for me to curtail
my lifestyle.
Look at smoking less,
trying to drink less,
like things like that young guy.
What's the logic behind red meat?
Less I think.
I,
I'm not at the doctor.
Does the doctor have a method to his
madness?
Like,
just yeah.
It's like if you read the list of like,
yeah,
things that are good or bad for your
ulcer.
So things that aggravate it.
Exactly.
So red meat like falls into that
category.
It was funny microphone but chicken
doesn't fish doesn't apparently not or
at least you know,
less so weird.
And uh,
yeah my,
cause my special lady friend,
she was like,
you know,
worried about me and stuff.
So she was reading up on like,
you know,
ulcers and things like that.
And it was like the first,
like there was like seven things that
like,
that flare it up at all of them were
like check marks for exactly what I was
doing in my life kind of thing.
Like,
you know,
I like I said red meats,
smoking,
drinking,
like I had just had like a neck issue.
So I was taking a lot of Ibuprofen and
it was just like every single check
mark,
you know.
So,
yeah,
I've read something about Ibuprofen
doing it because Ibuprofen disrupts gut
bacteria and they believe that gut
bacteria,
what was there was something really
recent about that,
a real recent study.
They think that they found a new cause
for ulcers.
Like they've changed what they feed
these to think it was caused by stress,
which can do it like also like,
cause I just started again.
I have also had like I've just started a
new company and things like that.
So like I have that kind of stress like
kind of thing.
Like,
you know,
like,
like I said,
I,
I hit a lot of the checkmarks look at
when you say can do it.
I think what they were saying was they
used to think it can do it,
but now they think it's all a matter of
a bacteria in your stomach.
Yeah.
I mean I think that's a big part of it.
And also if you like,
uh,
cause I did a movie in Thailand,
like last year and uh,
came back,
you know,
came back with a worm.
So what are those like single cell kind
of like,
you know what,
I was getting the medication for it.
I was like,
so what do I,
what should I expect from this?
And he's like,
what do you expect you to get better?
And I go,
yeah,
but like,
you know what's like,
am I going to shit a worm?
Am I going to shoot out of it?
And they're like,
no,
this is one of those single cell ones.
But,
uh,
it made me more susceptible to like
getting ulcers,
you know?
So is this because of the antibiotics
that you had to take for the worm or I
think,
I think it just,
it messes with your stomach chemistry
kind of thing after that is when you got
the ulcer.
Yeah,
exactly.
Exactly.
So,
you know,
soon dealing with it,
it's actually,
it's actually not so bad.
I'm like,
you know,
I like,
what does it do to you?
How does it,
what does an answer do?
You know,
sometimes you kind of get a little pain,
things like that.
Uh,
um,
uh,
yeah,
look,
I mean at one point I was like shitting
like 10 times a day kind thing.
You know what I mean?
Like it was Kinda just like Kinda
loosens your stool a little bit.
Yeah.
It kind of gets mucousy like,
I mean I can go in,
I can go into it.
That's what I mean you're asking me?
Yeah.
All right,
cool.
Yeah,
I find this stuff fascinating.
It is fascinating.
I was like,
what just came out of me?
Ooh.
Also fascinating when you can't see
what's going on.
It's like behind the door,
what's happening?
And then it was,
I can't even listen to it.
And I was like,
what was that?
Was that chicken?
I don't know.
Like which meal was that one?
I'm like experimenting with my stomach,
seeing when it comes out the other end
kind of thing.
And Kenya,
did you experiment at all with
probiotics?
Did you do anything to try to this?
There's a fairly recent thing.
This has only been like in the last,
like not even two months looking last
night.
Kinarum yet,
like eight weeks or so.
So like I am just kind of easing into
this thing.
I have a list,
I made a little list of like things that
are good for me,
like you know,
like to eat it,
things like that.
Like,
you know,
make sure I get some yogurt,
like lots of leafy Greens,
you know,
ribbon on your jacket that you've pinned
to the safety pin patient badge because
cause I participate in life,
look at me.
So what it's for?
Yeah.
I mean no I mean I went to a a um,
it was a camp like a summer camp themed
wedding,
uh,
back in like almost a year ago.
Something like that.
And so like they were giving out
participation badges,
like kind of thing.
Cause if you're participating in things,
but yeah,
no,
everyone always asks me about the,
the ribbon.
Like,
cause I kinda just like safety pin.
Yeah.
It kind of just,
you know,
like,
I mean I wear like all kinds of things,
but for some reason everyone's like what
does that,
what's that?
No,
I'm participating in life.
Here I am our entire look here.
I'm on your podcast.
You are a participant.
I am participating.
You seem really healthy.
Like you seem like a,
like a together person.
Oh yeah.
I know.
It's really,
again,
a shocker for people,
I guess.
So look,
you know,
I'm actually usually for the most part,
I'm pretty put together.
Look,
I,
you know,
yeah,
look,
I,
I got a good life now.
I got to have special lady friend.
We have a dog and a cat for a family.
Yeah,
exactly.
Like there's one thing to like exchange
keys.
It's another to get a cat,
you know,
so we had as you can get a cat together
cause it can kind of go anywhere.
Yeah.
You get a dark together.
That's a,
that's a big one.
That's a certain,
yeah,
she already had the dog,
but it's like,
it's a,
it's a girl and she's a she,
but you knew what I,
it looks like a stuffed animal kind of
thing.
And then,
um,
then we have a,
and she's black,
uh,
and then we got a big fluffy white cat
and it's like boy,
girl,
dog,
cat.
Like,
you know?
Yeah.
Like,
you know,
yeah.
They're really,
really,
and they're adorable.
Like I've seen dogs and cats play with
each other before and it's kind of cute
and these guys play all the time.
It's actually like,
it's a very special little relationship
that they have.
So cute.
Oh yeah.
No,
we never turn on the television,
look in her house and just watch the,
we just watched like the dog and the cat
and stuff,
you know.
Yeah.
Do you,
do you plan on making people?
Oh yeah,
yeah.
No,
I,
I want,
I'm going to make some babies,
you know,
that kind of stuff.
So get this one.
So this one's a good one.
So I'm probably gonna put some babies in
her looking a little bit with,
you know,
I mean we're,
we're definitely been practicing,
but uh,
yeah,
that's,
that's important.
Yeah.
But,
uh,
but yeah,
no,
yeah,
this one,
again,
I'm going to have a,
going to have some pretty,
she's a,
um,
she's Asian,
so I'm going to have like,
yeah,
I'm going to have little tiny little
Asian babies.
Yeah.
It's nice.
It's going to be adorable.
Dora a bunch of bunch of,
uh,
Sean Lennon's written around the house.
That's what I'm looking for.
Oh my goodness.
Yeah.
No,
cause it's funny,
like,
you know,
uh,
I like,
it's almost like I feel entitled to make
like Asian jokes because I have an Asian
girlfriend kind of thing.
But like,
you're loud.
I don't think I'm a,
well,
I do it with her like all the time,
but like,
I don't do any public.
Oh yeah.
I know.
It's like,
it's like,
oh,
oh baby,
you're my Yoko.
Like,
you know,
just like,
like,
yeah.
She's like,
you're going to be my downfall.
The most hated person in all of music.
Yeah,
yeah,
exactly.
Exactly.
Look in here.
It used to be able to,
if you were married to an Asian woman
10,
15 years ago,
be no problem.
I think if I,
I think if I have Asian babies,
I'd be allowed to even think so.
Man,
I don't even think so because,
you know,
I,
I'd had to deal with it every kind of
like,
day kind of thing.
It's like,
oh well I can,
you know,
I understand the struggle kind of thing.
You know?
I'm trying to shield my kids enough.
Yeah.
You don't come down to such white male,
wealthy,
white male who's famous.
You don't have a chance,
I guess.
I know,
right.
All those boxes to buddy.
Yeah,
it's true.
It's true.
Privileged blonde haired area and male
who grew up famous.
Yeah,
exactly.
They're just warming their fingers up.
Right.
They're probably write a blog about you
thinking that you can make Asian jokes.
I know,
I know.
Well,
that was one of the things that like,
you know,
one of the things I really loved about
her like was,
I remember when I made my first like
Asian crack liquor and just went to
just,
and she couldn't have stopped and then
she was like,
laugh.
She was like,
I can't believe you said that it.
I said,
you know how I know you're Asian?
She goes,
why?
I said,
this is the shape of your eyes.
It's dead giveaway
and she couldn't stop.
She was,
that's funny you're allowed to say that.
Yeah.
I can't say because the way you drive
bitch.
Yeah,
I know exactly what,
you have to have a really good sense of
humor to accept that.
Yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
But you don't have a special
relationship where you guys talk to each
other.
Maybe you are such a good driver.
Like just,
you know,
like just like,
yeah.
Just like no.
Like she's like shut up.
Would you stop with the Asian stuff?
Like you know,
cause she actually,
she has an excellent driver so you could
tell her you're a really good driver for
yeah.
Because I don't even know why that's
weird.
I don't,
again,
I don't forget I even brought it up.
I'm so not racist.
I don't even understand why that's
weird.
Exactly.
Like,
I mean I believe me,
I'm pretty relentless.
But her family,
like they also like they're,
they're down with like the,
you know.
Yeah.
It's,
it's,
I wouldn't even call it a teasing.
It's just like you're just telling jokes
kind of thing.
Looking at,
yeah.
Cause I'm the only,
I'm cause I'm the only white boy.
Like,
you know,
when we were visiting the family,
it's like,
I mean,
what brand of Asian?
Um,
uh,
it's tie a Laotian.
Oh Wow.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I know,
I know Leo Ocean know.
Yeah.
Uh,
I just got back from Thailand.
I was just there.
Yeah.
First time ever.
That's where I caught my worm.
Yeah.
So what is this warm like?
Did you find it?
Was it under your skin?
Was it,
didn't know what I mean,
like I said,
it's like a single celled kind of when
it's in your stomach.
Oh,
it was in your stomach?
Yeah.
How did you know you had?
Uh,
I had a lot of fatigue and again,
like just like my movements weren't all
that great,
like things like that.
And I remember waking up after about
like a good,
like week or so of it.
We had just wrapped up like,
we were like there for like five,
six weeks or something.
Uh,
so I was back in the states and it was
just,
I was sleeping like 20 hours a day.
Like only like waking up to like,
yeah,
like just to like just shit pretty much.
And then,
um,
and then,
uh,
yeah,
no,
I actually,
I remember waking up one of those days
and I said,
I'm pretty sure I have a worm looking to
actually just popped in my head.
I go,
look,
this is probably what a worm feels like.
It was almost kind of a mano s kind of
like fatigue,
like that kind of thing.
And so have know went there,
some like heavy duty antibiotics for
like 10 days.
How do they think you caught it?
Um,
I'm not sure.
Like,
well,
you were on heavy duty antibiotics for
10 days,
that's probably what caused your ulcer.
Yeah,
exactly.
You know what I mean?
Like the worm doesn't help.
And then the heavy duty antibiotics and
like all that stuff,
just kind of look at it.
And also,
again,
like lifestyle,
like kind of things,
you know,
like,
yeah,
just like,
like,
you know,
like I can't pound bourbon like I used
to kind of thing.
Like you didn't look,
that's kind of the idea.
Um,
so,
um,
but yeah,
yeah,
no it was so I think I caught it from a
cat cause there was actually like a,
we were in a,
uh,
it was Kopi p the,
that,
that island and then that's like cat
islands and we had these little
bungalows and I remember I was like,
we were just kinda checking in and I
pulled my bag up and there's like this
little like kind of kitten just like
walked up and it was just like,
look,
hey,
can I come in?
And we're like,
yeah,
sure.
Come on in.
Look,
I,
I've had a lot of cats in my life and
stuff,
so yeah,
that little,
uh,
that little sucker like spent a lot of
time and things like that.
And that's probably exactly what we'd
sleep in the bed together and stuff like
that.
Like Zur Bert,
you know,
like,
you should be tested for toxo plasma
toxoplasmosis.
I've actually had that before.
When you have it then yeah,
you have it for life.
Yeah,
exactly.
No,
I went through the symptoms.
I caught it from an under cooked piece
of lamb,
actually.
Yeah.
It's one of the four ways you can get it
kind of thing.
Uh,
no kidding.
Yeah,
you can get it from a yeah,
from cats.
You can get it from under cook lamb,
you can get it through a blood
transfusion.
And I think the other one is a mother
can transfer it to its B to their baby.
We're looking,
I believe me,
I went to the whole CDC website and
everything like uh,
um,
and that was like mono kind of thing.
Like a lot of people catch it but they
like they just have the antibodies for
it.
And I was a little rundown.
I was doing a play in London for like 10
months and also that kind of going out
at night and things like that.
So I think my body was kind of just like
not it's strongest and boom,
it hit me like a ton of bricks.
Like it was,
it was like mono kind of thing and I was
totally run down.
It's,
I got better after about like three
months or so,
but I didn't get a hundred percent
better for about a year.
There was a crazy article just written
about toxo that it had some sort of
impact on people who are,
who startup businesses that the
entrepreneur,
more entrepreneurs have toxoplasmosis.
It's a radically affects behavior
apparently.
Oh yeah.
I mean,
I don't know.
I got it when I was like 20,
so I'm going to ask.
So it makes you more risk taking more,
more.
Um,
it makes you more than hair.
Yeah.
Parasite founding cat poo has been
linked to higher likelihood of
entrepreneurial behavior in people who
get infected.
Yeah.
Well,
Hey,
I just launched my own website recently
and they,
that kind of stuff,
you know.
Yeah.
So they go,
I blame the toxoplasmosis.
Have you read up on it a lot?
I mean,
any of Robert Sapolsky stuff?
No,
no,
not in a while.
Like,
you know,
like,
I mean,
like I said,
I got this like in like 2000 2001 Paul
Skis.
Uh,
he's a professor at Stanford and a,
he's a biologist and he's,
he specializes in toxoplasmosis and
primate behavior and a lot of of his
biologist.
Right.
So this is a discipline.
But anyway,
he,
um,
he's got some amazing talks on it.
You really should listen to it since you
have it.
Yeah.
It's fascinating stuff.
They found a disproportionate number of
motorcycle victims,
people,
motorcycle crashes taking you were
saying.
Yeah.
That's actually,
yeah,
that's fascinating.
Yeah.
It,
you know how it works.
So it only,
it can only reproduce inside the cat's
gut and it rewires the sexual reward
system of a rat.
So it makes a rat horny when it smells
cat piss.
Oh.
So it completely changes the cats sexual
reward system.
Yeah,
no,
that makes sense.
Excuse me.
The,
uh,
the,
um,
like evolutionary advantage,
you know,
of pending to habit,
evolutionary advantage.
It's a,
it's,
it actually tricks the cat into killing
the rap and tricks the rat into being
horny.
They tend to come around.
Yeah,
exactly.
That's what I mean,
there's an evolutionary advantage to
them because like,
yeah,
like if you,
if you're a cat and you have
toxoplasmosis,
like it's going to,
uh,
you know,
it's going to,
to attract your pray to you.
Well,
it actually doesn't know.
It doesn't work that way.
Um,
it,
the rat has to be infected.
When the rats infected,
then it smells cat urine and it gets
horny when the cats,
in fact,
it doesn't do anything to the cat.
It seems to have no change in the
behavior of the cabinets and it gets to
people.
Yeah.
So it only affects really the behavior
of people and rats.
Yeah.
It's weird.
But yeah,
no,
I caught it.
I got the,
uh,
got the antibodies for it or whatever.
It's one of those like forever kind of
things,
but it doesn't affect me like at all.
Like,
you know what I mean?
There's no hell urgent issue.
Oh,
health issue.
Yeah.
That's what I mean.
Like,
yeah,
no,
it's like a,
it's just,
it's a,
you know,
it was one of those things where like,
yeah,
I got sick for a couple of months and
then boom.
I'm,
like I said,
it was like Mano,
I think it was just tired.
Disproportionate number of successful
soccer teams that come from countries
that are of high rates of toxoplasma
infection,
I should get into soccer.
Well,
it's just one of those things.
It's just,
it,
it changes the way people behave.
Make some,
make some little wilder.
So,
uh,
you're saying you're,
you're interested in some toxoplasmosis
and the might already have it.
Yeah.
Tacho your checked Tuxedo Gundy or
whatever it is.
Looking at [inaudible] [inaudible]
hasn't gotten,
was this movie in Thailand?
Uh,
is,
my buddy has,
seth green was a,
he wrote and directed a movie and so he
asked me to do something in it and you
know,
like,
cause I don't really pursue acting like
at all off kind of thing.
And now I'm not saying it was a favor or
anything like that,
but at the same time it was like,
yeah,
like it sounds like fun.
So,
uh,
it's cool cast.
It's like him,
he's in a brick and Myers and it,
uh,
Brenda Song,
me.
So do you just like do whatever you want
these days and just occasionally act
when it comes up?
Yeah,
if it comes up,
like,
you know,
if it's a cool look,
neat little gig or something like that,
like,
yeah,
sure.
But like I said,
I don't pursue it in any kind of like
any way,
like I don't have agents anymore and
things like that.
Is that because you're just not
interested or kind of 19 shit?
I don't really like the,
uh,
the pursuit of it,
you know,
like,
yeah.
Like what it takes to assess.
Exactly.
I don't like,
I don't like being on the circuit kind
of thing looking at.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
but yeah,
no,
I,
um,
you know,
I write a lot,
I paint a lot.
Like I just kind of always have like
some kind of projects.
And then also,
like I said,
we've got the website,
a bunny ears.com kind of thing.
And what does that,
that is a,
it's a comedy website.
It's pretty much,
uh,
like,
you know,
how all these celebrity,
especially like ladies,
they have those lifestyle websites,
all of them.
Well,
a lot of them do,
you know,
look at it like Goop,
it was one of them that I know of.
Is there other ones?
Oh,
yeah,
yeah.
No,
it's like,
yeah,
it's a goop ones.
The most egregious though.
Yeah.
Well that's the thing is that,
so this is,
this is like goop meets the onion.
A scoop is like goop meets the onion.
Yeah,
I knew all yet.
But accident accidentally,
you know?
Yeah.
They're telling you to put jade balls up
your vagina.
I know.
Believe me,
we,
we had a banana years.
Yeah.
We have,
we have an article beach in a hot,
hold on.
What does that do?
That thing.
Oh,
annoying.
How to have sex on a beach in a hot tub
and other things that seemed fun as a
virgin.
It's Hannah Hannah.
She's a or hunter.
She's at fantastic writer.
And you got a little scroll and things
like saying you have a podcast as well.
Yeah,
we do a podcast also.
Um,
and we're,
we're revving up some,
uh,
more like video content and things.
But uh,
yeah,
so this is just a fun project.
It's got a lot of really great writers,
like comedy writers and stuff.
Yeah.
It's kind of just like,
oh look,
there's a good article about a jade egg.
Like,
oh,
I put a jade egg up by her vagina and I
catch a jade bird,
you know,
like that kind of thing.
Like,
you know,
and then like,
I,
you know what to do about your bird
living in your vagina.
Now it's like things like,
you know what I mean?
We're,
we're kind of like taking the piss out
of like,
you know,
some of these kind of like lifestyley
websites,
you know,
it's like,
um,
you know,
they'll have articles like on coop about
like,
oh,
the best cabernets like for like $200 or
something.
That,
and it's like,
ours is like the best Bourbon's under,
you know,
$20.
But then like,
it turned,
the spelling gets worse and worse and
then it turns into a rant about your ex
girlfriend.
So like,
things like that,
it's,
it's some really good stuff.
Like I said,
we have a really,
really great team of,
of people and uh,
yeah,
it's kind of like I said,
taking the piss out of things and stuff.
So you just decided to do this just for
fun.
Yeah,
I kind of had this idea,
it was kind of kicking it around and so
forth.
And then I felt like I kind of
accumulated enough ideas and then,
uh,
yeah,
then I started kind of vultron owning
it.
Like just grabbing the assembling,
you know,
like this,
this,
this project,
this giant,
giant robot,
you know?
Yeah.
So there we go.
It's,
it,
it's a lot of fun.
It's,
and it's,
it is funny,
like we have a look,
I said there's actually a look.
Those articles are really well written,
like we have one about,
um,
uh,
do you see infinity war?
Uh,
yeah,
the vendors were,
because,
oh,
it's fantastic.
It's fantastic.
But we were like,
we made our own infinity gauntlet.
And what happens is like in a spoiler
alert,
uh,
is like,
a lot of the people kind of just vanish.
Like they kind of just die.
Like,
you know,
they turn into dust in a movie,
in the movie at the end.
So like when you start reading the
article,
uh,
um,
eight,
all of a sudden,
just all the words just starting
vanishing.
And then you have to go back and,
and again,
it's like a,
even like the letters,
like we actually had a,
a,
um,
we did one where it was a ransom letter.
Um,
one of our writers,
she,
um,
her father is actually the therapist for
Goop,
like the extra like psychiatrists,
the official one.
So we do pass their own therapist,
you know?
Yes.
But is it like a weekly advice therapist
or is it just like therapy just for
being on goop?
Like I know you're here because you're a
mass,
so here just read this,
read this.
It's okay.
So we're here for you.
So we got pictures of him bound and
gagged and it's like dear goop,
like we kidnapped your therapist,
uh,
w you can only get him back if you give
us your seven hot tips for,
you know,
yeah.
Like,
uh,
for facial washes for this summer and
you know what?
They actually good on them.
They responded and they actually like
sent us over like a list of like,
here are the hot light.
Kind of like,
I was like,
you know,
good for them.
Like they had a sense of humor about the
whole thing.
Look at again,
they have two,
they're called goop.
Yeah.
We won't,
we almost,
we thought about naming ours Puig uh,
that's probably sue.
Yeah,
I know.
I was like,
Hey,
look at me.
so you're basically financially set from
all those movies.
So I do okay for myself,
but do you just put that money away and
just live off the interest is how much?
Pretty much,
you know.
Yeah.
And uh,
yeah,
I've,
I'm able to kind of live the life that,
you know,
like that I,
that my circumstances afforded me.
I'm,
like I said,
I'm very,
very,
very lucky.
Um,
you know,
lots of weird things happen to kids all
the time,
all around the world.
Every day.
You know,
I,
I have something to show for it,
you know,
like,
yeah.
Like,
you know,
so it's nice.
I can,
I can live.
Um,
what does it,
it's uh,
my buddy jack,
he goes to a weird way to describe a
movie career.
Yeah.
I'm pretty much weird things happen to
kids.
Yeah.
Man.
I some money out of it.
Look,
I'm not working like the diamond mines.
I'm going to child soldier.
You know what I mean?
Like,
okay,
I came up the other end,
uh,
and you have something to show for it.
And I'm very like,
I do feel blessed every morning kind of
thing.
Let's see.
You're happy that it all worked out.
That one.
Yeah.
You can go back and do it again when you
do it the same way.
Knowing what I know now.
I mean probably I probably,
yeah,
I probably be even more charming.
I do it just better.
Of course you would,
right?
Yeah,
exactly.
Now imagine if you'd just have your
brain in a little kid's body.
Uh,
yeah,
I know.
I,
I would kill it grade school.
I would so kill it.
Like in school,
like Oh,
psychological warfare.
They wouldn't know what's coming.
Yeah,
yeah.
Just their little brains up and nuts.
Exactly.
That would be great.
I'm pretty sure that's what a 30 going
on 13 was.
Right.
And that goes to Jennifer Gardner movie.
I have no idea what any Jennifer garden
wounds are.
Well,
you know,
now you do three going on 13.
Yeah.
Like a a brain swap one kind of.
Yes.
But she like,
yeah.
How original or adult brain goes into
her
freaky Friday you're looking at,
yeah.
So it's kind of a freaky Friday with
some time travel.
I guess so.
Yeah.
So you're gonna,
you're gonna,
you're going to Netflix it tonight,
aren't ya?
Nope.
I could tell it that can,
that can see it.
Like you've been thoroughly charmed by,
uh,
Jennifer Gardner.
I can tell him interesting life you have
then you,
so you just kind of do whatever you
want.
Yeah.
My friend Genx is,
I'm a man of leisure.
That's the way he described.
It's like my life and lifestyle.
That's a good way to describe it.
And it's true.
And look,
I kind of looked at him kind of,
I'm going to spend some time just like
jumping around like Europe or something
like that.
Like,
you know,
and just like where you lived in Paris,
who were saying,
yeah.
Lived there for a number of years.
I mean,
I still have,
I still have my place there,
but,
uh,
since like 2013 so many things,
it's only in the last year I've been
kind of spending more time in the
states.
Was it that brought you to Paris?
Well,
the food sucks.
The wines terrible and the women are
ugly.
But uh,
but otherwise it's fantastic.
Yeah,
no,
it's okay.
It was an agreeable lifestyle.
I did a bunch of friends out there.
They were always asking me,
what are you gonna move to Paris and
winning to learn French.
Okay.
Like the or your friends in Paris.
And I was there just kind of like,
I was just kind of jumping around a
little bit.
And so,
um,
I thought about it for a second and I
went,
you know what,
how's next week?
So I said,
I'm going to leave my bags here,
I'm going to fly back to New York.
I'm going to going,
you know,
I'll put my affairs in order.
And I said,
I'll be back next week.
I said,
I'll,
I'm ready to live here.
I mean,
I realized that if I could pick up and
just move to France on a whim,
um,
and it wouldn't affect like,
you know,
like anyone's life or it wouldn't hurt
anybody or think I'd be remiss if I
didn't look,
you know what I mean?
Like,
yeah,
like how many,
how many times am I like,
I couldn't do that now,
but I could do it back then kind of
thing.
So it was like,
yeah,
like,
no,
I should just fuck it.
Look,
I'm,
I'm good.
I'm going to live in Paris now.
Gonna yeah.
And it was,
it was great.
It was a lot of people who've done that.
Johnny Depp lived there for a little
while.
I know Richard,
he still has a place there for awhile.
You know,
it's,
it's a special place.
I mean,
what's special about it?
Um,
I mean,
again,
food and wine's fantastic.
Like the girls are pretty,
like,
it's the leisurely kind of like
lifestyle a little bit.
Like I like,
I like their eating habits,
I get it.
It's like a light breakfast and kind of
gets heavier as you kind of go along in
the day.
Uh,
you kind of eat later,
which is kind of like,
you know,
like,
oh,
you're American,
you must want to eat dinner at like
eight in the time of day.
I like 10:00 PM 10:00 PM is like a,
you know,
kind of,
uh,
you know,
ideal like dinner kind of time.
Um,
they don't like to work hard either,
right?
I mean,
no,
I mean they,
I mean they work,
I mean,
I think,
you know,
I like to take their time and yeah,
everything is like,
yeah,
it's like,
you know,
I'll sit up a card game for like three
30 and three 30 means like five,
you know,
again,
that's just the way,
like everyone's kind of always late,
but it's no big deal.
That's the thing.
I remember one time coming and I'm like,
oh gosh,
like,
you know,
it was just like,
where are they kind kinda.
And then I realized,
I'm like,
wait,
what is the hurry w for real?
Like what is the hurry?
It's like,
I have other plans.
My plan is to hang out,
like,
you know,
with you guys.
And so,
and all of a sudden the stress would
just kind of just melt away.
I'm like,
yeah,
like look,
you can just be more leisurely and
stuff,
uh,
about things out there and everyone's
looking at,
like I said,
it's,
it's really cool.
They like Americans out there.
That's a misconception and if they don't
like,
they don't like the loud,
obnoxious Americans with the,
you know,
mickey mouse tee shirt and the fatty
stuff.
Yeah,
no,
it was a fanny packs.
How dare you.
And I did.
I did have one.
It's all right.
Yeah.
Wonderful.
Yeah,
you got it.
Yeah.
Got Nice.
Like leather one,
you know,
I used inside pockets.
I got,
I got an insight that that's my purse.
Well that works too.
I also have this,
I have a Satchel that I,
I travel around with also like,
yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
You know what,
it's actually,
I do call it my purse,
like,
you know,
in day to day kind of thing.
Cause it's like someone's like,
oh,
that's a Satchel or it's immerse.
I'm like,
no,
it's a purse look like no,
no illusions here.
Isn't it funny that you would be
insulted or more positive about it if
had a different sound coming out of your
mouth?
Right.
And it's like,
no,
no.
It's exact same thing.
It's purse.
Yeah.
So,
um,
what happened there?
Why did men,
how can we can a person,
right.
No one's going to do that.
Like me know there's a few bold souls
that we'll put on a fanny pack and walk
out into public.
Yeah.
But it's not a lot of people that will
just ask you just called yourself bold.
There's not a lot of people that would
wear a,
uh,
an actual purse,
like a Louis Vuitton purse.
I mean,
I'm secure enough in myself and like
everything like,
like yeah,
I can pull up the purse.
Look,
I mean I wear fingernail Polish and you
know,
I have participation badge.
Like I've gotten like I did you have
like fingernail stripes?
Yeah,
all Polish.
But like a little bit.
Yeah.
I actually,
I almost,
I actually do it on purpose.
Look aids,
they do make my fingers a little too
feminine if it's done perfectly.
So,
but I'm actually really good.
When I did that movie party monster,
I learned a lot of like,
just fun makeup.
He kind of things and ways to make your
fingers look like they're like,
you're like,
look,
there are two weeks old when really
liking her yet technically,
I mean,
I could've like painted these yesterday
and they would look like this kind of
thing.
Yeah.
But I'm always,
I always just like nail Polish in and
say,
you know?
Yeah.
Um,
but yeah,
no,
I'm secure enough to like wear a purse
or something like that.
Like,
you know,
I want to shoot with that.
Oh No.
I don't have to wear a backpack though.
That's where it's weird.
What's this Mickey Rourke.
Oh yeah,
he's got,
uh,
what are the school that was called a
clutch sit.
Yeah.
That looks more like a clutch.
But he's so eccentric.
I met him this past weekend.
He had a crazy cowboy hats.
We're looking at a picture of Mickey
Rourke.
You had a crazy cowboy hat on and he's
just,
yeah,
he's,
he seems like a cook.
I mean you can see that that belt buckle
like really like that one is,
you know,
that's something I'm looking at again,
look good on him.
Yeah.
And he's just an odd duck.
I for some reason it reminds me of,
it was an old onion article and it's one
of my favorite headlines and it was
Johnny Depp found to be 90% scarfs.
Yeah.
He counted like way scarfy after the
whole pirate movies.
Yeah.
He went straight scarf like where are
the rest of his life kind of thing.
He was like,
yeah,
he,
he really,
he really committed to that scarf thing
when you're a beautiful man like that.
It's an odd transition to being like a
55 year old.
I like what's up with Johnny Depp
lately?
Not good things.
I know.
It's,
it's really strange actually.
They just,
this morning they delayed or like
actually like or canceled.
He is a notorious B I g movie looking at
that.
He's in with forest whitaker,
uh,
and it was suppose to come out next
month and they just pulled it from the
schedule and they haven't like even said
it's ever going to come out or
something.
And it's like,
and even just like looking at pictures
of him,
like it kind of just like there's
something off about him and hope he used
to be,
he used to be really great.
You said,
you know,
what'd you do to him?
You fuck,
I don't even know who that is.
Doug Stanhope one of the best standup
comedians ever.
Uh,
there you go.
He's a,
I'm more of a Steven Wright fan myself.
Me Too.
Yeah.
No love Steven.
Right.
But I think,
uh,
I think Johnny's just,
he hit that weird spot where you're just
too fucking famous.
You can't go anywhere where you were
when you were little,
I'm sure.
But you can coast now,
right?
You can go places like how,
how rich is rich enough?
Like,
dude,
like ground look.
Yeah,
look,
that's what it means.
Not just that,
but he spends,
he only 14 houses.
He owns an island.
Millions and millions of dollars.
Did he spend like $5 billion shooting?
Uh,
uh,
a hunter s Thompson is the Canon.
They them like,
did you spend $1 million?
Cause no,
of course not.
I spent $3 million.
They asked him about his wine habit.
They
said,
uh,
your attorney said that your wine habit
is $30,000 a month.
And he goes,
that's an insult.
It's far more than,
it's far,
far more than that.
Now that's,
you mean like how lean and like,
all right,
cool.
Like I guess she has to maintain it and
you know that lifestyle.
Well that's what he wants for himself.
That's what he's doing.
That's his life.
His life is spending all that money.
Yeah.
Like his whole life is doing movie that,
you know,
people though also when they're,
they're involved in laborious projects
that they're not really interested in.
You know,
when you're,
when you're doing something all day,
and I say this is a guy who hosted fear
factor
that you don't really enjoy doing while
you're doing it,
you're like,
okay,
time to go to work.
I mean it was very thankful to have the
job.
Don't get me wrong,
but the reality is it was not enjoy.
It wasn't a fruitful endeavor.
It wasn't like working for the UFC are
doing standup comedy or even doing a
podcast.
It wasn't a passion project.
Exactly.
So when you do something like that,
like people on bad sitcoms in
particular,
they spend all their fucking money.
They go crazy.
Yeah.
Because the only thing that they look
forward to is what am I going to do with
this money?
We're to buy a Ferrari,
I'm going to buy a mansion,
I'm going to buy an island.
That's,
I think that's what Johnny got into.
Yeah.
I,
I couldn't see myself like doing a
sitcom or a television show kind of
thing.
Like what about a good,
a good one?
I do like news radio's a fantastic show
look like you must have been that.
That must have been like a fruitful
endeavor.
Reason why I never did another one.
Yeah,
exactly.
They don't want to ruin that experience.
Every other one that came along was
like,
this is shit go.
They,
they pursued me for,
for me,
for a big bang theory.
Oh Christ,
you got lucky and didn't get that.
And I said,
no.
I said like,
no,
cause it was kind of like the way that
pitch was,
it was kind of just like,
all right,
these two like astrophysicist nerds and
then a pretty girl lives with them.
He links like,
you know,
and like that was the pitch and it was
like,
yeah.
And they're like,
oh,
we're going to get some real like
physicists to like,
you know,
do the math.
And I said,
no.
I said,
I'm cool.
Like thanks.
And then they came back at me again and
I said,
no,
look.
I'm like again,
flattered.
But like,
no.
And then,
then they came back at me again and then
like even my manager,
it was like twisting my arm and I like,
listen,
I'd have hundreds of millions of dollars
right now.
I feel like if I did that Gig at the
same time,
I'd be bashing my head against the wall.
That's the thing.
Yeah.
I think that's what Johnny Depp's doing
and we can't really be into those pirate
movies.
Yeah,
no,
he's just,
he's interested.
And that's the thing is that like,
he wasn't always like that all,
it's like all about the money.
Right.
This is a thing,
I read an article,
an interview with him,
it was about two decades ago and he was
talking about,
you know,
he was in his thirties,
and he was doing a lot of weird,
obscure movies.
Like what's that movie,
dead man,
that black and white?
Yeah.
He did a lot of weird shit.
And he said,
this is kind of what I really like and I
don't,
I'm not blockbuster boy,
which is what he said.
It's so ironic.
Ironic.
They had no,
the couple pull quotes and blockbuster
boy.
Yeah,
no,
he goes,
yeah,
if I ever,
like if you're,
if I'm ever a part of like a franchise,
like just shoot me or something like
that.
Yeah.
They're pulled up these weird like old
quotes.
It was a,
um,
it's like the George Lucas,
like when he,
uh,
he testified before Congress about the
colorization of movies and talking about
how movies are or are part of our
heritage and you know,
they shouldn't be tampered with or
anything.
He goes back 25 years later he's going
back and redoing his movies and it's
like,
yeah,
no,
like once you put art out there,
leave it alone,
leave it alone with,
no,
it's not yours anymore.
Like that's the thing,
like once you show like your paintings,
like that's not yours anymore.
That's the worlds,
that's an interesting way of looking at
it and you don't think it's theirs
anymore.
Imagine imagining Divinci like,
like just all of a sudden came back into
existence right now and he wants to
change the Mona Lisa.
She's fat.
Like I kind of didn't get,
I didn't get the smile right?
Yeah,
exactly.
It's all pulled back and shit.
I want to say it.
So should he be able to change it?
I want to give us some fucking jewelry.
I never finished the eyebrows.
I want to give a big tits.
Push them together.
God.
Let me try mine.
Come on.
It's my fucking painting.
Yeah,
exactly.
I met,
we are Devinci is a moderate Italian.
Yeah.
You know I love it.
It's,
yeah,
it's like
big tits would fucking glitter.
It's like he's like a living.
I'm like Mulberry Street and like in
Little Italy.
Hey Pizza.
Yeah,
I like a fake lips.
It's where I want.
Give me some claims casino.
Hey,
this fucking broad.
Look at a look at it.
Now,
who is talking about that theory that
some people believe that Leonardo
Davinci,
that Mona Lisa was him in drag.
Yeah.
That it was a self portrait.
Who has it?
That when I was bringing up,
Kalin said that the other day.
Yeah,
I've seen,
I've seen those things.
What does it pull up a picture of him
with this and what we never did.
We only pulled up a picture of the
photo.
We never pulled up a picture of him and
the photo.
I wonder if that's,
that's fascinating.
If that really was the case.
If he just decided to paint himself and
drag.
Well,
they found all kinds of things in that
painting.
It like in her like,
like her irs of her eyes.
There's actually like,
like letters in there and stuff like
really,
really tiny,
like straight Illuminati.
Demon comes right out of the ground.
You know,
I had a dream,
the demons were real last night and I
just remembered it.
I just had a,
I had a dream where I was stupid amount
of Steve,
almost 51 years old dreams,
you know?
Yeah.
But that's how we fucking thought a
dream the other day where I was the
biggest dick in the world.
Like I was actually just being really
rude to everybody.
Here's the,
there's a drawing of him.
Wow.
It's like looking in a mirror.
Yeah.
Nailed it guys.
That's it.
Oh yeah.
You know,
you can kind of size anything into
anything.
Yeah.
Well I don't know about that one.
And the head's a little tall.
Might have gotten confused with that.
You know,
the drawing of the demand and the circle
in the square and the portraits.
Well,
you know,
maybe imagined yourself as a woman.
I mean that's not necessarily him.
And drag.
Like I,
I've imagined that before.
What would happen if I was born a girl?
What I look like that same.
I just stare at myself naked in the
mirror every day.
Look what I got for Ya.
Yeah.
I dress like a dude just to fuck with
pimple.
Look at Mike Duties with Michael Angelo.
Um,
he,
I always used to get them confused.
Leonardo Da Vinci.
Leonardo Da Vinci was the one that
invented a bunch of shit though.
Yeah,
he was,
he was the renaissance man.
Yeah,
no,
he was also kind of an engineer and he
actually made like,
or at least like,
you know,
like,
uh,
it was like,
like a tank kind of thing.
Like,
you know,
like plain plain as well designed.
But he designed,
uh,
like weapons of war also.
Like it wasn't just like airplanes,
there were at least gliders and
helicopters and so forth.
Uh,
but yeah,
no,
he got he,
yeah,
look at all the different shit that he
came up with that just tank.
Wow.
So when you see the ship and you can see
like there's like kind of like,
like holes for like guns all around and
it's like wheels.
Like I,
I'm not sure easy.
I'm not sure if they actually built it
or not.
That's like a kill everybody tank.
There's so nondescript with where those
bullets are going.
They're going to three 6,360 degree
spinning that thing around.
But yeah,
no,
he made,
yeah,
he,
he actually liked designed weapons,
but those,
those were cannons.
It must've been right.
Probably that's what it kind of looks
like.
You can have really guns back then
there's in that design and cannons.
Oh Wow.
That is crazy.
Yeah,
no,
he was freak.
He was a,
he was rad man.
Well keep me hanging out with that guy.
Yeah.
Right.
Just,
you know,
draw me like one of your French girls.
How,
how weird the weird guy.
Yeah,
no.
Yeah.
Michelangelo,
the Sistine Chapel and he's actually
more of a sculptor than a painter.
A a crossbow.
Invented.
Yeah,
but it's like a giant one looking at.
Yeah.
Like one of the ones that they killed
the smog with.
Look at the multi gun.
The Kim was kind of invented a machine
gun,
like the one just left to that.
Yeah,
it's a bunch of gun barrels.
It's a bunch of gun barrels and it was
like almost like a,
it's like the first design for a machine
gun essentially shoots in multiple
directions.
Looking at,
yeah.
I,
I would really love to talk to an
extraordinary person from back then.
It must have been so different.
Hey,
give me some claims casino away.
Look at this fucking guy.
Look at this airplane thing.
Yeah.
Like a glider,
you know,
I like to talk to Picasso or to talk to
Davinci or any,
any of these people from exceptional
people from a long time.
It was like my,
my favorite leisure when it comes to his
paintings and stuff.
But you know,
I,
I heard he wasn't necessarily like,
you know,
the,
the like coolest person to be around
kind of thing.
You ever seen the,
uh,
there was like,
what's the deal with him?
I think he,
he was,
he was an artist.
He was very aware that he was Picasso
lucky.
No.
Like he was,
yeah.
He was already like the most famous
painter in the world and he knew it kind
of thing.
He,
uh,
he actually used to walk around,
he didn't carry money or a wallet.
He just carried like a pad.
So if he wanted to get like a,
a pack of cigarettes,
he kinda just like,
eh.
And they go in like that.
So He'd ever had to like pay for
anything because he was shit.
Yeah.
He kind of say,
Eh.
And,
and listen,
would you accept that trade?
A pack of cigarettes for a Picasso?
Like,
yeah,
I'd take that trade.
So are those around?
Yeah,
he actually has a lot of like little
sketches,
like all around,
they're actually quite affordable,
at least in terms of owning the Picasso,
the keys,
you know,
he was very prolific and just like a lot
of like ink drawings and so forth.
I remember there was the snl sketch,
uh,
it was like love.
It's was playing Picasso and he's like,
but like he kind of,
I think it went around kind of just
doing anything he wanted and he's like,
it's because I'm Picasso,
like,
you know,
and he was just like,
just being in church.
Everybody you mentioned love.
It's doing that.
You don't love it because I'm PAC caso
that's a good lump.
It's impression.
Oh,
thanks.
Thanks.
Yeah,
there you go.
He was on news radio for a whole season.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
After I have to fill.
Yeah.
I hung out with him.
He's a good guy.
Yeah.
I've always like every time I bumped,
bumped into him.
Very,
very nice person.
That really,
really sweet.
I ran into him at,
um,
I went to the,
uh,
with my buddy seth green.
We went to the peewee Herman a Broadway
show that they had a bunch of years back
and yet I ran into love.
It's like they're backstage,
so it's like,
yeah,
just like me,
Seth Greene,
peewee Herman and Jon Lovitz.
And I'm like,
this is quite a,
quite a little little get together.
This is,
this is great.
This is a great table.
I was doing standup for a while.
I don't think he's doing any more
because I don't see him anymore.
But a few years back he was doing a lot
of standup,
like he was,
he bought,
he bought the Jon Lovitz Comedy Club.
And universal universal is the worst
comedy club design of all time.
Well,
you know,
it's,
it's weird that he was actually able to
find a club that was already named after
him.
He wouldn't,
what are the,
what are the odds?
He bought a place.
It used to be the house of Blues.
It was,
no,
it was bb King's club.
It was bb King's Blues Club.
And he turns it into the John Lovitz
thing.
And um,
he was,
wow.
That's really interesting.
I'm remembering that I saw Sean Penn had
that older brother,
that big brother that died crispin.
I saw that guy there,
play the harmonica,
hammered one onstage and play the
harmonica and hey,
I'm Chris Ben.
That was some weird Hollywood thing.
And I was like,
wow,
imagine that you're so famous.
You just jump on stage at a blues club
and play the harmonica and everybody's
happier.
They're like,
oh,
weird.
Yeah.
But uh,
I was hoping it was gonna be like Sean
Penn jumped up there and did like his
tight five.
But you would be on,
that would be strange.
John Mayer does stand up.
I've heard that.
Very strange.
So if you're on stage bb King's
place,
like if this was a stage,
there would be a balcony,
but it would be above you like way up
there right above you.
And so like you'd have to look up to see
the people that are white.
So they're basically looking straight
down on the top of your head.
Worst idea for design,
but it's not as serious when you're
seeing music,
you know,
you don't necessarily have to be as
connected to the person's face.
I've been to,
I've been to a place where actually like
you were literally right over the band
and that was kind of neat.
Like actually watching,
watching the drummer from overhead,
like kind of,
it's kind of neat.
But yeah,
no,
just like just watching somebody with a
bald spot on the top of their head.
And that's really close.
Yeah.
And there's Lebanese and hey look at me.
And they gave me pain,
fanny and down clapping.
I'm back.
I sell.
I imagined it was taller than that.
That's interesting.
My memory's not that good.
Yeah.
Getting whole day.
Yes.
Well it's just getting weird because
it's got too much shit in there.
My brain has too much information.
So you're running that a room?
Oh,
for sure.
I'm a deleting space on my hard drive
for new thing.
Yeah.
And like seventh grade I went to seventh
grade done cheese.
Oh God.
What happened to that seventh grade?
Funny that you know who needs curse if
am I right?
I wonder what John's doing.
I'm one.
I wonder why he stopped doing standup
because he was actually pretty funny and
he was,
it was weird because he was already
famous and one of the things was like I,
I had tried to encourage Phil Hartman to
do stand up several times because he
would do standup where he would warm up
for the,
you know,
the,
the crowd would be there for the show.
And in between scenes,
there was always some downtime and Phil
would take the warmups microphone and do
bitch riff,
do like his Bill Clinton impression.
This was during the whole Monica
Lewinsky scandal.
So he had like all this material about
Bill Clinton and Monica and his
impressions were amazing.
Yeah,
yeah.
No,
he's like,
he's one of my favorites of all time on
that show.
Yeah,
he was amazing.
And so he was thinking about what does
this two shows a night?
Where is he?
Huntsville,
Alabama,
still doing stand up.
Look at that.
He didn't give a fuck.
Look at them out there with those
glasses is great.
Hey,
he looks happy.
He looks at 14 likes.
Hey,
I'm Jon Lovitz
looking on my legs.
Yeah.
So he's still doing it.
Interesting.
Good for him.
Like I said,
I always liked him.
Great Guy.
When I did SNL,
I think it was the first season where he
had,
he had just left.
I think because I did it pretty much
probably if I had to pick a season,
I would have been,
would have been that when I did.
Because you still had carvey and you
still had,
you know,
Hartman and Victoria Jackson,
like the whole kind of group,
but I forgot him of Victoria Jackson.
She was fucking hilarious.
Yeah.
What happened to her?
She's a hardcore conservative now.
Huge like right,
right winger.
She's put on a little weight,
you know,
but I haven't wheel and uh,
yeah,
no,
she's actually a hardcore conservative
now.
Like she,
she shouted from the mountaintops,
what was she like when you met her?
She was fine.
I mean listen,
it was she conservative.
I was,
I was busy doing the show kind of thing,
you know what I mean?
Cause it's a lot of work and mature now.
He,
that I had to do a,
um,
I had to do it without cue cards cause
my father didn't want me to use cue
cards.
So I don't like to memorize all that
stuff.
Plus plus plus the skits that didn't
even make it into the show.
So I like,
I had to memorize like schizo didn't
even end up in the sheets.
Yeah.
Dad,
you know,
like I said,
I had a good memory and he didn't want
me reading.
You know,
cause it,
you can see it,
they can see it when people are reading.
And he didn't want me to do in that,
so.
Wow.
So Nokia card,
but also that means the other actors do
cue card for them either.
Yeah,
of course not.
You know,
they had like,
yeah,
no,
I'm sure my father made a lot of friends
looking at him.
Like,
you know,
that that weekend,
well that's fucked up.
Like how can he dictate whether or not
the other actors get cue cards?
I don't know.
Cause it's
because he apparently he could.
Victoria Jackson's a hardcore
conservative,
so straight,
like I said,
she shouted from the mountaintops and
again,
active.
Yeah.
So she was like,
you know,
so it was that whole kind of group,
that kind of late eighties group.
Uh,
but then also it was a,
it was mick Meyer a second season,
I think,
you know,
it was in,
it was like,
you know,
Schneider Sandler,
Chris Rock,
you know,
so it was like that kind of overlap
year.
So I actually got like a really kind of
like really good group that lingo.
So that was awesome.
That was neat.
It's always weird when someone from like
a TV show gets really political.
Yeah.
You know,
like,
like a chuck woolery from the love that
guy is,
he's so fucking crazy conservative.
Oh really?
Yeah,
his twitter feed.
I go to his twitter feed every now and
then just to see what crazy old men
conservatives are really interested in.
How often does he use the term fake
news?
You know,
the libs and got dems,
the Dems and the libs.
They outright,
you know,
he's kept,
apparently he's got a like a radio show,
like some like uh,
like all what we make sense and it's one
of those things,
you know,
no nonsense.
Blunt Force,
truth,
blunt force truth.
Yeah.
You Damn Liberals.
It's kind of more like,
kind of like it.
That sounds like a band from Brooklyn.
Look at it.
Three d printed farms are a concern for
crime,
but criminals will do bad things no
matter what.
Find out more by listening.
End Up Blunt force truth.
Look at that.
It's Hashtag bft wow.
He's a,
he's pushing that and I said,
listen to some of that just for he,
he isn't.
Haha.
Yeah,
I know,
right?
You should all show follow James Woods.
Oh,
goodness.
Yes.
It says it right there.
Right?
You like this look like that.
All dudes do you want to put up giant
gates
so they're going to get solar to what
happened?
What happened after Peter Fonda?
He's super conservative to now,
isn't he?
I don't know.
They're just democrats to commit voter
fraud.
Oh,
the opposite.
It's the opposite.
Yeah.
He's a super,
Super Democrat.
Rosie turns feud with trump into
activism.
Bitter rosy.
All caps.
Trump rallies are real.
His supporters are paid black forest
truth,
truth.
True.
Just look at you.
Oh,
look at that.
Some journalistic integrity from chuck
woolery.
That's his whole thing though.
His whole thing is that now I think he
lives in Texas or something.
I think he escape California and all the
crazy libs.
That'll be right back in two and two,
two and two.
I forget the name of that show.
I remember.
I used to like it.
That went on the game show network.
Don't want that.
All the boxes and it was like letters
and stuff.
Uh,
fuck.
I forget the name of it.
Uh,
what's that?
So many shows.
Yes.
Yeah.
I only remember the love connection.
I add like 10 maybe.
Yeah,
the game show network.
Yeah.
Like when that launched and they're
like,
yeah,
we can get,
we can get chuck woolery.
So
I'll go on if you'll let me talk about
the damn libs.
Yeah,
exactly.
TRIBEC and was busy like,
you know,
he's already busy on his own thing,
but we can get woolery how weird and
what was the guy scrabble or lingo too.
We can go,
there we go.
Hi.
Welcome back.
I've got a tie and cue cards.
What is it?
It's an e.
Oh,
look at that.
Look at those two dorks.
I'm wearing sunglasses on TV.
So much judgment.
It's fun.
That's fun to do.
Oh yeah.
To be judging.
Yeah,
exactly.
It's just fun.
It's fun.
I actually kind of need to pee.
Go Pee,
man.
I cool.
Don't worry about we live.
Yeah,
but it doesn't matter.
I'm going to go ski guys.
Dude,
we'll talk some shit about chuck woolery
naturally stoned game show.
You go,
go van did a show called naturally
stone.
Come on,
get the fuck Outta here.
He has a what?
A song called naturally stoned.
Oh,
what is that?
This naturally stoned and American
reality television show that starred
American game show hosts chuck woolery
six episodes aired in the game show
network in 2003 between June 15th and
July of 27 series centered around the
woolery and his family,
specifically his personal life and his
work as a host of gain show networks.
Original game show lingo.
The show place drain on both woolies
workload and his marriage.
It says the series title is derived from
his top 40 song from his band.
The avant garde.
What?
He had a sh what I thought.
Fuck what he had a band.
Chuck woolery had a ban psychedelic pop
group.
Get 67 fuck I a flight.
Get the fuck out of here.
You got to find song.
A psychedelic pop group.
Oh my goodness.
Chuck naturally stolen psychedelics,
but natural site.
He had a pop band.
Yes,
yes,
yes.
Naturally stoned.
It was a,
um,
it was like a mamas and the Papas esque
kind of like sixties,
like kind of song.
I think he probably was trying to do it
on the Nache though.
Okay,
let's listen to some of this.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
that's him right there.
Naturally stone honey and gall
to pull it off of Youtube.
Otherwise we'll get pulled.
So the people listen on Youtube.
You got to go google avant garde.
Naturally stoned.
The people that are listening in on,
uh,
you know,
Google play and itunes and all that
shit.
You can hear this.
Yeah,
I know.
This is a very like incense and
peppermints kind of terrible
like,
yeah.
Okay.
Just got terrible.
Keep going.
Oh my God.
Sounds groovy man.
Yeah.
Chili's stoned.
He's still match,
release toned and there's chuck.
Wow.
Look at Chuck Upfront when we were at
back in two and two,
two and two.
He's got wooden beads on does that
wooden beads around his neck to both do
like,
look guys,
we got beads on,
we're cool.
Feel like I'm at a party,
like on Haight Ashbury or something like
that.
And then you know,
I want to fun late sixties the guy in
the back with his hand on his hip.
See what the fuck he's up to these days.
That is the other guy that's pet say
jack
honey and gall like what is that?
I think it's the name of the album.
Oh,
that's the name of the album.
I don't know actually.
I know it's probably the byside elk in
Bubba Fowler Elkins got a duck hunting
show on the sportsmans channel.
Now this guy
I'm getting,
what is he doing now?
He's a Leonard Cohen.
Leonard Cohen.
The [inaudible] yard.
How strange it is.
I think blunt force truth is a better
name for a band and the avant garde.
Yeah,
it is,
right?
Yeah.
Tonight at the pit blunt force truth,
you don't want to know the truth
phenomena.
It's blunt,
blunt force.
What a weird name for a show.
Blunt force truth,
spitting hot truth right in your face.
Just spitting it.
Spit,
not fire that you don't want to hear
shit.
Hot Fire.
Wake up kids.
I always looked at it.
I always loved that line from a
Chappelle.
It was like,
ah,
I,
you know,
I spent hot fire and it's just like I
said,
if there's cold buyer,
I'm spending hot fire.
Right.
And you're cold fusion.
What else?
That's so strange that that whole thing
that he's,
he was in a,
Yup.
The avant garde to,
gosh,
that is so like the of that era.
It's so funny when those old dudes get
like real all from 1974 look at that
chair burns very Jay Leno ask in that
photo.
Yeah,
we'll get him here.
Gimme some volume and we hear him sing
here he goes,
oh my gosh.
Yeah,
he definitely has a nice voice.
It's like a bad voice.
Hmm.
Oh yeah.
Oh I've heard this song before.
This is a cover.
Okay.
You make me so very happy.
Yeah,
this is a cover.
Okay.
Kill is,
how do ya,
how do you go from the outline card to
like,
yeah,
like hosting like you know,
well because dating game or whatever
cause this isn't good.
Yeah,
there you go.
And weird transition.
Well he's a handsome guy.
Probably a good talker.
And his agent was like,
chuck,
Chuck,
I'm telling you the mood,
the music is not your thing cause yeah,
hosting.
I'm going to give you the blunt force
truth.
You don't want to hear it but I'm going
to tell you.
He's like,
Michelle was like,
I like that phrase.
You've got to look.
You've got to look chuck.
The look is game show host.
You got it.
You have it.
How about you being on the game show
network?
What do you think about that fella?
Just anyone actually ever aspire to be a
game show host?
Oh for sure.
I know,
I know.
Like you know,
but like when you're a kid,
you know what I mean?
Like you want to be an astronaut or
whatever.
It'd be someone who's like watches,
Zach,
Zach Morris from saved by the bell.
He wanted to be a game show host.
He's on a real person.
I know.
I'm just saying,
I'm just making conversation right now.
There's some kid right now who's fucking
dream.
You just shattered
my dream.
No,
I was just happy I was asking her
question.
It was a legit question like,
you know,
like yeah.
Do people aspire to be a game show host?
Yeah,
for sure.
Well,
I know in the UK like host is a thing
that people aspire to be like,
I got to ask somebody,
what are you doing?
He's like,
I host.
I'm like,
what's that pain to get there?
They usually got panelists on like a
show television presenter.
Presenter.
Exactly.
Yes,
yes.
The presenter.
That song actually gave them,
there was so,
so much of a hit that they were a one
hit wonder then and he had to become a
truck driver to simple bent supplement
his income.
He then signed on as a solo artist,
had five more songs on his own.
Didn't obviously work out that well.
Then he became the first dose of wheel
of fortune and 1970 [inaudible].
Oh,
I didn't
say Jack's been doing it since 1981 I
love that.
That's great.
So how long did he do it for?
Six years.
Five,
six years.
Wheel of fortune for six years.
What year did it start?
75 so it was a year after that.
After that thing.
We just watched.
So it was it one year later,
six years.
I hope he still had that hair,
that mane of hair.
He still does a thing.
Yeah.
Those,
there's little like the sideburns,
the mutton chops.
No Man.
Old School ones go down to your job.
Mallory Dispute
Chuck and then didn't get to go straight
to say Jack.
Imagine he fucking turns it on.
It's still on the air.
He's like
my age.
It's a piece of shit.
That's the blunt force truth you want
out of the blackboard.
I have regrets.
That's the truth.
Maybe he didn't want to do it anymore.
Maybe that's what it was.
Contract negotiations went straight into
like the dating game or whatever.
Show get to see chicks,
I guess.
So they're trying to get laid.
So did you got it?
You got chicks and dude's trying to get
laid or facilitator putting love
together.
I mean,
you know who got the most action was a
Richard Dawson family feud.
Oh yeah.
He always kissed every like lady on
don't even like the ones that were
underage.
Did you ever see that movie with the
thing is speech.
See gonna Richard Dawson,
the guy who was in Hogan's heroes with
him.
What was that fucking movie?
Oh,
like
eight or eight millimeter.
One of those.
It's not that the movie where who?
What was that guy's name?
I don't know.
He was apparently he was the guy who was
the star of Hogan's heroes and then he
just became the freak of the week.
He just got homemade porno.
That's all he did.
That's all he did,
and then they think the guy he did porn
with killed him.
I believe his murder was never saw,
but there was some sort of extenuating
circumstances that connected his,
his porn buddy.
The guy was in the movie.
I think they maybe that was what they
implied in the movie.
I think that was what it was.
Well,
if it was in a movie,
it has to be true.
You know it.
They don't ever lie.
Man.
Crime.
That's the thing about movies.
When they do a story about your life,
they don't change shit.
No.
They literally get every word right.
Otherwise they would lose credibility.
Yup.
Yeah,
yeah.
There's,
there's movies where they change shit.
You're like,
why did you change that?
Like they just decide to like his
historical things like,
oh it's creative license or like we have
to condense things because a person's
life is like,
you know,
so long and things like that.
Do you remember that movie about um,
the,
the movie with,
uh,
it was with,
um,
what's his name from the office?
Yes.
Steve Carell.
He played that catch her.
Yeah.
We were both thinking the same thing.
I was just waiting to get the
description cause I was going to say
foxcatcher he's back.
No,
not that,
that movie's based on two very famous
wrestlers,
Dave Schultz and Marshall and in the
movie they put a ton of bullshit in
there and don't mean a lot of in mark
was furious when the movie came out.
I remember reading that and he,
you know,
he went on a crazy wild twitter storm.
But then after that,
like the end of the movie,
He,
there's a historic moment in that,
in that movie that they just completely
made up.
Like he fought this guy named big daddy
goodrich in the UFC.
I mean it's,
it's sports history and in terms of the,
it sounds like that sounds like a wwe
wrestler.
I know it does.
Could have been a wwe wrestler,
but a big daddy goodrich who's,
you know,
really a pioneer in mma fighting,
um,
was this big fucking Jack Black Guy who
wore a,
a gay,
he wore like a traditional karate
getting into the octagon in the movie.
They have him fighting a white guy,
a Russian guy,
whitewash.
And they just decided they don't want to
see why guys.
Yeah,
no,
I'm going to put her wasn't as America
we have,
we have to fight.
The Russians was like,
why would you change the race and the
name of the guy he fought?
Yeah.
Just seems like weird and like petty
almost till you know what?
It's this weird greasy producers who
think they're smart.
You've been around them,
you know those fucks.
I have no idea what you're talking
about.
Tell,
tell him.
Let me tell you,
I'm going to give you the blunt force
truth right in your face.
Sit Hot.
Fire
fucking lips.
They,
uh,
they,
you know,
they just decide they're smarter than
everybody and they know better.
They know how to change history and make
it,
make it a better show.
And like I said,
well,
you know,
we were,
it was the eighties so look,
yes,
it has to be against a Russian kind of
thing.
Wasn't the 80s well,
I'm saying it takes place,
isn't it the case?
Please note takers in the 90s.
Yeah,
it was a,
I think he fought in 1995 or say no Kurt
Angle,
like I know a trained,
uh,
in that facility,
the Fox catcher.
Yeah,
he's talked about that.
You know how crazy that guy was just
decided to set up some wrestling thing
so you could get like weird with these
dudes,
like a bunch of strong sweaty men like
rubbing up against each other.
It's,
I bet you those red lose like wrestlers,
like when they're training,
I bet you whoever their training with
knows their body better than their
wives.
No,
it's a really intimate thing.
I mean,
like,
I bet you they know every curve of their
trainee losing weight here at Tom.
Yeah,
exactly.
I'm going to cinch this grip around.
Your waist just feels like a little
easier.
No,
I,
it is intimate sport.
We're not some shoulder muscle
weight a little.
So all that,
you know,
say I had a gun and your baton.
Yeah,
I remember when he was like in the movie
Steve Carell was so good in that movie.
I loved him and that God,
he played that creep so well because he
played it like a guy who's like a loose
cannon,
like creepy,
weird and loose cannon,
small,
you know the way he kind of like his
movements and his speech.
It was good.
I remember when he was like,
he decided he was going to coach and
coach the wrestlers and show them how to
do certain moves and everybody just sort
of tolerated.
Then they're kind of like,
oh let them and let them have this one
strain.
But what a great scene.
But here's the thing like that,
that scene was so good,
but now I know you lied at the end.
So I know you lied to the end of the
movie.
So now I go,
well,
did you make up that scene starts losing
credibility.
I did watch it.
I did watch
a doc about that.
I think there's a 30 for 30 about the
Fox catcher institute or whatever it
was.
There was a lot of footage on that guy
and Corel fucking nailed it.
Dupont,
dupont,
dupont.
Yeah.
What a strange,
strange guy.
That guy was mister dupont.
That's a unfortunate thing about those
wrestlers.
Like there's no real professional venue
other than fighting if they want to go
into mma.
And he was a coach at Brigham Young.
Mark Schultz was and he just,
he fought one time in the UFC and then
just stayed.
They,
I don't think they wanted him doing it.
I think that was part of the dispute is
that his coach believe it was Brigham
Young,
his,
uh,
the school that he was coaching for,
it was like,
listen,
you want a coach here?
He can't be cage fight.
Cause especially like early,
like MMA was not respected at all.
I remember John Mccain trying to let you
know,
again,
like it was a blood sport and he kept
on,
you know what that was about?
That was about Budweiser because
budweiser sponsored boxing and MMA was
doing very well with paper view back
then and they wanted to uh,
stop it in its tracks and budweiser was
a big part of that.
And Budweiser sort of got behind him.
It's all greasy.
Yeah.
I mean the boxing world is so Greece
cause I'm a fight fan at least like
boxing.
I was kind of like,
we're always kind of raised that way.
Like I do follow it.
Um,
uh,
I've only recently kind of gotten into
like the Nma and kind of stuff.
I've gone to some shows they're going to
see any sporting event is always great
life looking at do you go to live boxing
matches though?
Having been a while.
Uh,
but yeah,
I like I especially,
I used to,
like,
I used to go to like I,
I saw a holyfield more or one digit
really.
I saw a holyfield bow one,
things like that,
like,
yeah,
during that kind of peak,
you know?
Yeah.
That was that nineties era did it,
did a lot of those.
Um,
but uh,
those were great,
but that stuff is so greasy,
you know.
I remember the first,
uh,
Holyfield Louis like that,
how that ended in a draw so they could
double up their money and stuff.
Remember that fight?
I don't remember how we feel versus
Louis at all.
Yeah.
They fought twice Louis when the first
time no draw one draw the push shitty of
one.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
You know,
I was,
it was,
it was a great boxer,
but at the same time I just remember
being driven nuts.
Like where he was like,
wait,
where is like belt like up to here?
Like it was like way past his belly
button and he's 48.
He's already like six,
six already.
And it's kind of just like,
yeah,
like he's,
he's wearing that thing too high.
Like,
you know,
like he's getting away with murder like
you,
what kind of thing it shouldn't,
you know?
Yeah,
absolutely.
I'm surprised you've got away with that,
you know,
that that equipment,
but both,
most referees will tell you you can hit
him here.
Yeah.
But you know,
like I said,
it was kind of just,
it felt like an unfair advantage,
especially for a guy who was like,
like I said,
six,
six getting at and so ready.
Enormous.
Yeah,
exactly.
Like,
you know,
he's,
so,
it's even higher than normal and that
would be a big target for somebody who's
like only like casino.
So you follow boxing today though?
Yeah,
I'm really looking forward.
You know,
I want to see wilder versus a Joshua
look,
that's when I want to see in the
heavyweight division for a while tasting
fury though.
Like he's kind of back in the ring and
the ties fewer in my them all up.
That's
a problem because they're all big guys.
They are big guys.
But Tyson fury looks fucking fantastic.
There's some footage on his instagram of
him doing pad work and he's fighting
really soon.
He just bought like a warm up kind of
like,
you know,
some journeyman.
But it's got about coming up.
Uh,
well Tyson does.
I think,
I think it just happened like air or
something or does he have another one
coming?
I think he's got it.
I'm pretty sure he's got another one.
I'm a big deontay wilder fan.
I am too.
Yeah,
like it's just,
it's wild man.
Unorthodox and like man,
the way he fucking slugs the Jesus
Christ,
which is vicious power.
Oh yeah.
I'm watching those highlight reels and
just like,
yeah,
like I mean it's give that guy a
seizure.
There was that one where the boom,
the guy land scene just like,
it's like a flapping around like a fish
and it's like Jesus Christ,
he has fucking hard because he's like
six [inaudible] seven.
He's a big dude.
He is long too.
Like crazy leverage.
Get those.
He was,
cause he really snapped his right
looking at boom,
the recent one.
Yeah.
That was back from like was losing that
fight and then stopped or tea.
I thought it showed up like,
yeah,
it showed that he's got like he's got
heart and he's got a pretty okay chin.
He knows how to recover.
Who's your favorite fighter to watch
right now?
One?
Yeah.
Like I said,
I really do love watching wilder.
Like right now.
Triple g's good.
Yeah.
He's,
he's,
he's looking at it like he's might be
like an old timer kind of thing.
I just wish he'd kind of look how good
this guy looks.
Six foot nine,
give me some volume on this.
I can hear this.
And he's thick too,
but he's,
he's like showing how slick he is cause
he's,
he's not just big.
He's big and long,
but here it's here.
He told me,
he told me he toys.
He toyed with Klitschko.
Yeah,
man.
Dude,
he's fucking good.
And he gives people fits yet the new
rumors is supposed to be wilder versus
fury.
Now the Joshua like talks,
I'm like not happening.
Well yeah.
Um,
Tyson fury.
He could fuck up that whole thing then.
So it's the 18th of August and they're
both a little unorthodox too.
So it'd be actually interesting to see
like him square off with wilder.
Fuck yeah,
they're both super long.
Yeah,
that would be very interesting.
But I think it would be like the first
time who others finding somebody who's
bigger than him do not just bigger but
super slick.
He's going to give him fits.
Yup.
I mean look,
wilder can knock out anybody but Tyson
fury he,
he'll give you fits like that guys.
Cause Wilder is like what?
Like 37 and hoe with 36 knockouts things
once.
I know it's crazy.
That's a crazy record.
Yup.
It's tasting esque like young Tyson has
but then they're completely different
fighters.
Young Tyson was just so tight and like,
you know like and wilders,
he puts his hands down,
he wants to counter punch like you know,
that's his whole thing.
What's interesting is people still don't
believe in,
I'm like,
I had heard that the Anthony Joshua
fight.
Like I would think that that would be
like a pretty evenly matched fight that
people are like,
no,
no gosh,
it was heads up,
heads above everybody else.
It's like,
you know,
I'm not so sure.
Look,
you know,
you take it on some good challenges
though.
I mean like Joshua can go,
we can do some amazing,
don't get me wrong,
but he got knocked down by Klitschko
Tyson
fury toward with Klitschko putting his
hands behind his back and maybe it was
not the same as prepared a Klitschko.
You know,
fighters are different for every fight,
which goes like,
yeah,
like aging obviously.
Yes.
At that point.
Yeah.
But I just think that that style,
that Tyson fury style,
avoid that shit.
Like measles get away.
Yeah.
There's a reason why Joshua doesn't want
to fight wilder or fury.
Yeah.
Cause also he is the top draw right now.
Like he can sell out like,
you know,
like 40 50,000 in his home country where
it's like wilder,
like in his home state,
he's,
he fights a lot in Alabama.
Like it's like 10,000 or something like
that.
So Joshua was a bigger draw.
Well he's becoming,
I think while there is becoming a bigger
draw nationally now,
but I think that's also one of the
things with boxing.
He's like,
they're always trying to figure out
like,
when do we make this fight?
Do we make it now or do we wait a couple
of months?
Let me see.
The year undefeated champions find each
other.
Like that doesn't really happen that
often,
especially in the heavyweight division.
It could be like something that's like
really special.
Someone could fuck up and lose.
Yeah,
exactly.
Exactly.
It made me whether Pacquiao all over
again where it's like it happened,
but it happened too late.
Right,
exactly.
Yeah.
So it get stay the fuck away from Tyson
fury kids.
What'd you think about the uh,
the Mcgregor Mayweather fight?
It went,
he did much better than I thought he was
going to get me to.
Um,
but I think that may,
whether it was probably wanting to wear
him out and so allowed him to explain,
but he did catch me whether with a very
clean left was rabbit punching the whole
time that was driving me insane.
Just kept on just punching the back of
his head.
Like,
you don't like them.
I'm surprised that the left hand
hammered.
Exactly.
It's like,
man,
you can't do that.
Look at me.
And I'm surprised like the ref,
like let them get away with murder.
But
I think you wanted to frustrate me her
and get me whether to try to stay open
up.
Maybe whether it's defense is like
fantastic and like,
no,
he came in there like mayweather fought
a perfect kind of fight.
He's like,
just,
I'm going to let this guy get himself
out.
And that's exactly what he did.
Well because we were going to knock
knockout artist,
but he knocked him out.
He definitely stopped him.
But Connor is not known for his cardio.
He's,
yeah,
he's a fast twitch guy.
Yeah,
I think it was when they opened up the
books for that fight,
uh,
it was a thousand to one from Mcgregor
to win by decision.
I listen to,
I almost,
I almost put a grand on that just
anyway,
just on principle just to see like,
wow,
I just want,
I just want $1 million.
There's a reason why no one.
But I kinda wanna just sit there and
like turn to my friends.
Like I think I just won $1 million
crazy.
That would be to win $1 million.
We're putting dots,
I guess that was in del,
I bet
there's been some crazy,
but those,
those bets are nuts.
Like will it make it out of the first
round?
Well yeah,
yeah.
By decision even have like
disqualification beds.
Yeah,
exactly.
Again,
I used to play a lot of cards.
I love prop bets.
Just like,
you know,
like,
like in that moment it was like,
I bet you,
I can guess within,
you know,
a $100 how many chips are in front of
you.
Right?
Like,
you know,
like that kind of stuff or like,
or it's like,
all right,
like,
you know,
give me,
give me a,
you know,
one in 10 chance.
Do you pull out a dollar bill from your
pocket and whatever the last number is.
Like if I get it right,
you know,
you can pay me 10 to one look.
Just like weird prop bets.
Like people like,
like they like players like kind of go
nuts with that kind of stuff.
Well,
gambling junkies do.
Right?
Exactly.
Look,
I remember us playing cards at this one
club and uh,
this guy,
uh,
just was sports betting like crazy even.
But now it's like,
you know,
like two in the morning,
three in the morning,
and he's looking down.
He goes,
does anyone know anything about cricket?
Was like,
that was the only game that was going
on.
There's a cricket game in India.
And he was like,
yeah,
I'm going to like late.
I was like,
dude,
you actually have a problem like that.
It's like,
you know,
yeah.
Like you have to like,
like that's a problem.
You're betting on cricket and man,
it's two in the morning.
Anyone know anything about rick?
Well that's the crazy thing about those
sports books.
So you look up and wash that shit.
Here's our bunch of horses.
Yeah.
Who's gonna win?
I've actually,
I have a buddy who does it is into the
racism,
stuff like that.
And like he streams it from like,
uh,
it is kind of fun.
Looks racing.
Yeah.
It's kind of like,
but you kind of just randomly like,
just like,
I'm sure number eight,
you know,
come on eight.
I knew a guy who got banned for life
from chariot races for trying to rig a
race because he was his,
his horses winning and his horse wasn't
supposed to win.
This is literally standing up,
pulling back on the reins as his horse
was winning.
It's like he's trying to slow him down.
Cut It,
cut that shit off.
His name was George the Greek.
That's what he's calling.
Wow.
Guy From a pool hall and a White Plains
New York.
Yeah.
The Greek is like,
yeah,
cause it was Jimmy the Greek back in the
day,
you know?
Yeah.
He was always trying to like,
he was even telling us,
what is that?
It's a little vape.
Oh no,
go ahead.
He was always telling us that,
uh,
he was gonna win the lawsuit.
I got to counselor.
Counselor was his lawyer.
I got consolo slow economic case.
It's fucking thing.
I got him locked down.
Chariot racing.
How do you get into chariot racing to
too,
I mean obviously you need,
if it's a sport like yeah,
but like how do you like do you like,
like fall into,
how do you fall into that line of work
or again,
like when you were a kid are going when
I grow up I want to be a chariot racer.
He was a lot of that movie with a Kirk
Douglas then they cherish.
Yeah,
exactly.
Just like yeah you imagining himself was
like a bow and Arrow in the back with
those crazy risks plates where those
moving gas.
Exactly.
I gotta listen greaves like a crazy
movie.
Cause if you look at the difference
between like Spartacus and 300 right?
Yeah.
You look at Spartacus,
they had like normal bodies.
Like you guys just ate toast and you
know,
didn't work out back in like the Roman
days.
Like I would,
I was,
I'd be considered tall.
I'm five,
seven like you know like a lot of those
soldiers like you know like in spartans
and food they were like five,
five cause they probably have no food.
There was a,
there was a lot of nutrition,
I was gonna say to say malnutrition,
but that was kind of like,
it wasn't straight malnutrition,
it just wasn't good nutrition like kind
of thing.
A lot of like,
uh,
like salt,
pork,
you know,
like that kind of thing.
A lot of like weird flatbreads,
even just not a lot of none,
a lot of green there not a lot of
greens,
you know,
just grain and salted beef.
It was probably really hard to get good
food back then.
Like as you're,
as you're growing up,
you probably were always mounted,
nourished and no one was fat either.
Right.
And it's very rare that people are,
people were rarely fat.
Well that's why it's like a,
um,
like a fat lady,
uh,
like was considered like really,
really sexy because it showed that she
was fat.
She got some cash.
Exactly.
Yeah,
look at that.
That's why you see like that's why it's
like you see like the aphrodite like and
stuff like that and it's all very,
very curvy.
Yeah.
They went through a whole era where
those reuben ask women don't ask.
That was the thing.
That's what everybody wanted.
I want to give me a big guy,
some cushion for the pushing.
Now we're in danger right now.
We're treading in dangerous waters.
Even talking about that.
I know.
Take me to Kirk Douglas.
Find Kirk Douglas and spartacus
comparing them.
Sporadic.
The sporadicness.
It's um,
when you were in Paris,
did you know this?
Oh,
there it is.
Looking at,
Doug said a guy who's literally never
swung a sword.
Yeah,
he looks,
he looks a,
here are the ones,
he already looks old there.
Oh yeah,
he was,
well I bet he was probably in his
thirties because people back then just
aged worse.
Yeah.
They just,
I don't know what the fuck was going on.
That just,
they didn't age good.
And it's a,
it's the,
it's the liquor and cigarettes.
Cigarettes and liquor.
Yeah,
but you smoked cigarettes and you look
fantastic.
You look great.
I agree.
What does that,
yeah.
Let's say yes,
please take a guess how old he was
during spartacus in Linkedin.
I think he was a hair under 40 I think
you're right.
I would go with 37.
What is it?
44 oh yeah,
we'll say kind of looks like 44 today's
44 yeah.
Like Daniel,
Craig's Jack this fuck.
And he's probably like 44 how old Daniel
Craig right now.
James Bond.
But it doesn't,
he have like some like crow's feet or
whatever channel.
I know he's a thick daisy.
The 50 50 wow.
Really?
Just 50 mother fucker looking good.
How old are you?
50 Oh,
look at you.
Look at it.
You're a big dude.
Look at that.
Jacked.
You're a big dude,
but I can take you.
Whoa.
That looks like fucking James Bond in
May.
Not all these other pussies and he's my
all time favorite.
James Bond by far.
That's a real James Bond.
Yeah know I like his like,
yeah,
I liked his steely resolve.
My other favorite James Bond is a
potential James Bond.
I don't know if he's a James Bond yet.
Is Idris Elba Idris sell button.
That's exact.
And because
white people are mad,
they're fantastic for moving,
they get like Michael B.
Jordan.
It's like everyone just calm down.
Look at that right there.
Oh good Lord.
Luna's body.
Look at that.
This,
I mean,
he's already kind of got a little,
little like he's got the beginning of,
of meant it's not bad.
It's better than my body fat.
He doesn't look like a guy who fought
with a fucking sword for a living.
Yeah.
But that's how they,
that's probably closer,
like more accurate to what,
you know,
what actual,
like Romans and you know,
not if there were actual gladiator,
is there an actual gladiator they had a
swing swords around,
look at that arm.
Come on.
So I'm that army carrying those sorts
lean muscle.
It's lean muscle.
Wirey he got some,
he got some veins coming out,
bro.
He's jacked.
But um,
yeah,
this is Kubrick and people,
people always forget.
Yes.
Confirm that.
But yeah,
that's amazing.
Apparently he hated it too.
Like,
you know,
he hated the movie.
Yeah.
It was probably one of those things he
had to do.
Yeah.
Geez.
God,
I loved his movies.
Yeah.
No,
this is actually one of the weaker ones.
It's really never read the shining.
No,
it's really interesting.
Different.
Stephen King did not like it.
Yeah.
Oh,
the movie,
because they did the TV movie in the
early two thousands,
Stephen [inaudible],
Stephen Webber,
and uh,
he just decided that,
you know,
like Kubrick had made Jack Nicholson
crazy already and he didn't like that he
wanted a guy that was torn curtain crazy
by the house.
Yeah.
But then how the fuck are you going to
do that in a two hour movie?
You know,
it's not scary hedges,
you know,
like,
they was like,
they were like,
there's a thing,
it was like probably like,
you know,
I bet you if you,
you read it or whatever,
it's probably seems creepy.
Like when he's like talking about how
the hedges are moving when he's not
looking at stuff like that.
But when you physically see it,
it's not scary at all.
You know what I mean?
Like,
yeah.
Like it just,
like things like that.
Like,
just don't think that usually translate,
but it worked in the book.
The book's amazing.
The books really,
it's a big ass book too.
It's a Stephen King.
I mean,
they're all,
you know.
Yeah.
I think it's a big ass book.
Yeah,
there's a,
I'm confusing it with the dark tower
series.
There's also,
the stand is really thick too.
That's a dictionary.
It's a paper weight.
He was,
I mean it still is,
but so fucking prolific.
The thing with the,
the mazes,
it's like,
yeah,
like the macy's keeps on kind of like
changing like the one,
the one that you see in the model there
and the one that exists and there's also
a map on the outside of it.
All three of those are different and the
bushes and get a look from the top.
I think it's like kind of more like
stems.
I don't think they were like thick
branches.
Hack your way through.
Walk Straight.
Yep.
No,
it's true.
Plus he's scared of bushes.
What are you scared of?
C'Mon,
c'mon.
Well,
the hedges that are moving in the book.
So monsters.
Yeah,
there team and hedges.
It's kind of like,
you know these like,
like Edward scissorhands ask,
like kind of like,
you know,
it's a kitten.
You know,
it's like,
and then it's like,
Ooh,
it's moving when you're not looking and
like,
oh,
that's an adorable cat hedge that um,
that place,
well that's supposed to be asked this
park.
Is that what it's supposed to be?
That area?
It's supposed to be somewhere in
Colorado that's like that.
Yeah.
I mean,
I think that's where they filmed it,
or at least the out,
you know,
the outdoors.
Some of it.
And I think they filmed some of it also
in upstate New York.
There's a place like,
yeah,
but like,
and then they get like a studio,
I think.
I think it was in London.
Usually Kubrick worked in out of London.
But yeah,
the overlook hotel.
There we go.
It actually is like,
it's not called the overlooking in real
life,
but yeah,
it's in Colorado.
Yeah.
That was a fucking great movie.
So creepy and weird.
Yeah.
You shouldn't so many of them remember
eyes wide shut.
That was another one that was,
that's his last movie.
Yeah.
A lot of people didn't like that one.
I thought that was fascinating.
I,
you know,
I'm a little soft on it,
like at least when it comes to like,
I mean it's still great.
Right.
But I can,
I put it lower on my coo lists.
Um,
uh,
yeah,
clockwork orange 2001.
I mean like,
you know,
yeah.
You name it,
you know,
during his spare time he used to do
complex mathematics.
That sounds about right.
Yes,
that's right.
It was like a legit genius.
Yeah.
He has a um,
archives in,
I think it's in London,
but there's actually the standing cooper
like library and yet she can kind of go
through his scripts and his notes and
all that kind of stuff.
Looking at,
there's like a whole like archive that's
supposed to be kind of pretty neat.
Do you see yourself over making movies
like producing or directing or writing?
So if it's,
you know,
peaks my fancy kind of thing,
he peaks my fancy,
uh,
I'd be open to doing something that,
you know,
like a,
um,
it's a matter of like kind of the right
kind of thing,
timing and so forth.
Like right now it wouldn't be ideal,
but like,
you know,
a year from now,
like yeah,
I probably might be a little freer.
Like that kind of thing,
you know?
Yeah.
Like,
you know,
hopefully the company will be moving on
to tailored by that and kind of thing.
Okay.
Here's something I want to ask you about
Paris.
This is one thing that I was only there
for a short period of time,
but one thing is I was shocked,
stuck,
shocked by you.
Shucked shook is that all those people
are eating a bread and they're all
eating cheese and wine and no one's fat.
Yup.
What the fuck is that?
Uh,
again,
it's kind of the way that you kind of
eat how you kind of had chemo.
You have a light breakfast,
but then a heavy dinner.
I think that has to do with it.
And also you can't call yourself a
[inaudible] like a bakery and less,
you make everything from scratch.
So everything's made from scratch aid.
Like the thing is just that like you're
like,
Baguette will be stale in 24 hours.
Same thing with the croissants.
Like there's no preservatives in
anything like all out in general out
there,
like all your food spoils faster like in
your fridge because like,
yeah,
it's,
you know,
it's fresh.
There's no hormones and things.
Steroids.
He was an oncologist from Paris and he
lived in America and he went back to
France and brought back cheese because
the cheese that he could get over there,
it was not homogenized or pasteurized.
It's literally illegal here.
So he would have to Tuck it in his carry
on or it is a check luggage and just
hope that no one would check when she
got the wheel of cheese.
Literally like walked back wheel,
excuse me sir.
And when he served it to us,
it was like precious,
this precious cheese.
I mean,
they make raw cheese and American now,
but this was,
but it's like specific and like,
yeah,
like you have to like,
you know,
it's like,
it's Boutiquey kind of thing,
cheek,
you know,
niche kind of thing.
No,
see thing with things like their eggs.
They don't refrigerate their eggs over
there because he's done in the different
kind of process.
Uh,
I think,
uh,
I forget what it is,
have eggs that I get from my chickens.
You don't,
I don't refrigerate them.
It's the first year after a while you
can just watch them.
But I think in America it's,
I think we like,
I think it's like we,
like,
like hit him with it.
We're like super hot la.
There's a different process than they
have in Europe.
So in general you're not supposed to
refrigerate it ranks.
There were in state states are supposed
to just a different,
it's a different process of how things
are done.
Yeah,
the preservative thing makes a lot of
sense.
The preservatives and I think there's
also,
there's also different shit that's in,
in wheat and there's different kinds of
wheat.
They have heirloom wheat,
wheat,
it's like older wheat before,
you know,
we started messing with it and they also
dairy cattle and things like that.
Uh,
it's a grass fed,
whereas in the states it's corn fed.
Right.
And also I just noticed like in general
out there like I was eating less red
meat.
You have a lot more chicken and a lot of
uh,
pig,
lots of ham,
like,
you know,
that kind of thing.
Ham is a very lucky no,
just what will they just dry it or
whatever and just cured legs when they
just take that thin slice off.
I'm actually going there,
uh,
going back in a couple of days.
So yeah,
again,
uh,
and you know,
we really nancy,
because I'm going out to Berlin,
I'm doing this thing,
it's called the people festival look out
there.
And so I'm gonna do something like
hanging out with some friends I know
like a good lake full fest.
It's called the people festival.
I mean it's a music fest and I know like
a good like 12 or 20 like of the acts
got like,
they're like my friends and stuff and
still get to like go to Berlin and I'm
going to be like the roving reporter
pretty well.
I found myself,
you know,
something to do.
Yeah.
It's going to be like podcasting and so
forth.
Cause there's a lot of like,
yeah,
like there's a lot of like cool
musicians doing it and so,
oh that's cool.
So yeah,
it's a,
so I'm kind of like fine from La to New
York spending the night cause I hate
taking like super long flights and then
New York to Paris,
a couple of days of leisure and then you
then you know Paris to Berlin,
you know it's you.
Even when you do that,
you tilt your head sideways and throw
your head back.
A man of leisure travel at my whim,
I should have a Manhattan in my hand.
Like ha ha.
Oh shall we booked you a straight flight
to Europe?
No,
no,
of course not.
That's too much time in the [inaudible].
I like to puddle jump.
I want to go to New York,
I'll go to New York.
Perhaps I'll shop perhaps a shop in
Paris in empower you go to a cafe.
Maybe I'll take the,
the channel to London just for a day
trip a day trip.
Me As I've,
I've a fantastic t shirt shop that I
love now.
One of the things that people were in
America that don't go to Paris or
worried about it.
It's like people hear horror stories
about the immigration nightmare in Paris
and that Paris is somehow or another
turning into this criminal cesspool
because of all these immigrants and it's
very dangerous there now.
Hence those shootings that you heard
about and the,
you know,
it is actually one of the most
ethnically diverse cities in all of
Europe.
Like I was actually like,
you know,
yeah.
You know,
you see more black people in like the
first five minutes of being there than
you do in the whole of like oslow or
like Berlin or something like that.
Yeah,
no,
it's,
it is like kind of,
it's culturally and ethnically diverse.
Um,
the,
you know,
when it comes to all this like shootings
and things like that,
they're guilty of being landlocked.
You know,
the UK can kind of control the,
the,
you know,
the flow of traffic,
people kind of coming in and out because
they're an island nation.
Whereas,
like with the kind of open borders,
if that you can,
you know,
you can buy a gun in Greece and take the
train,
you know,
like all the way over.
Like,
you know,
especially when it comes to like the
old,
uh,
at the,
like the Balkans or whatever.
Like,
you know,
there's a lot of leftover Soviet era,
like collision a cost.
That's why they always have like these
Russian made like guns and so forth.
Uh,
and yeah,
that's what I mean.
If it's easier for,
so,
you know,
somewhere like the UK to like lock off
their borders or at least have like,
you know,
we're as friends.
It's like I said,
it's guilty of being landlocked
essentially.
Um,
the,
you know,
they is more difficult to secure.
Is that the blunt force truth?
Yes.
Blunt force truth
bft row
and that's the bft.
Yeah,
there you go.
People should start using that.
The bft as the Hashtag bft t that's a
bft coming your way.
It's like,
Ooh,
delicious.
Um,
but they,
they,
the,
the big fear,
like the one thing that people were
terrified of was that this was going to
happen to the rest of Europe.
That like what,
what's happening to Paris and Paris has
fallen apart and you can go through some
of the ghetto areas and Paris and you
know,
there was a,
someone filmed something where a Jewish
man,
a walk through,
uh,
these,
Muslim ghettos and they're screaming
out,
I'm all these antisemetic things.
I have not seen that.
But you know,
at my neighbors,
uh,
only a couple blocks away from like the
Jewish kind of neighborhoods like that.
It's a good spot to live.
Heck yeah.
He was good to live near the Jewish
folk.
They keep it together.
Yeah.
So I'm like,
I'm already half Jewish.
You know,
I was in New York recently when we were
in Brooklyn and a,
I was with Arri,
my friend Ari,
who uh,
grew up Orthodox Jew and he took us
through this neighborhood where they
have like the crazy frisbee for hats on
the curls and they pay us and the,
the,
the fucking,
the yarn hanging off their belt,
all the weird shit.
And you know,
he was basically saying like,
these people,
like they are here but they're not here.
Like they don't know what the fuck is
going on.
They have no idea who Kim Kardashian is.
They don't listen to any of the music.
They all stick together.
They inner marry the Merion side of the
community if they get married young and
look at it.
And it's so interesting seeing them all
walk around the streets,
the sheets,
some of them do.
Right.
It's not acidic though too.
So there's just a,
just a hallway.
So I think just throw a sheet over and
just,
you know,
just perfectly framed the vagina right
there and I'll take care of it from
here.
They don't want to touch naked women.
Ryan,
is that the idea?
I think it was a modesty kind of thing.
Kind of like tradition,
kind of.
I just do that at home.
Just for fun.
Yeah.
He's like,
honey,
why are these,
why are there holes and all these sheets
show hush.
Jesus wants this or
God we killed Jesus.
Jesus was a Jew.
It's okay.
Um,
so like this,
this community that we were driving
through is massive,
like Brooklyn and it was going to say
Brooklyn,
like kind of in the southern kind of
parch massive community.
Yeah.
I didn't know how big Brooklyn was.
It's,
it's big.
Fucking huge.
It really is.
Yeah.
It's kind of like you're talking about
the neighborhood that kind of like north
of Red Hook,
but right there on the river.
Cause I bet I walked from my place in
Lower Manhattan all the way down to red
hook,
like one day.
And as long as it take maybe about an
hour,
an hour ish.
But that's it.
Yeah.
I'm,
I work at,
I walk in a New York Pace.
He must have been sprinting.
Yeah.
I,
I'm,
I'm uh,
I walk into New York base.
I'm on a walker.
That's how I see something that you run
seven miles an hour.
That's like a fairly good clip.
It's gotta be more than seven miles.
Um,
no,
it's actually,
no it's not.
You have to understand that the whole of
Manhattan is,
I think it's like 14 miles,
something like that.
14 by four and I'm already living in the
southern part.
Oh yeah.
It's probably,
I don't know,
like about three,
three miles,
three miles.
I've walked about three to four miles an
hour.
One of the guys that was there with us,
the guy who was driving us was telling
us how Brooklyn has just overwhelmed
with building construction apartment
buildings now.
And everyone's moving out of Manhattan
into Brooklyn.
Yeah.
It's,
it's because the thing about Manhattan
is that it's finite.
Look,
you know,
so the only way you can build upwards,
but you can only do that so much.
And so it,
I let people were getting like
displaced,
like you have to have enough money just
to stay on the island of Manhattan.
And even people like that are getting
displaced then like,
yeah,
they,
it's Brooklyn,
queens,
et cetera.
Hoboken,
the people that I know that live in
Manhattan always have this thought in
their head that one day they might live
in La.
Yeah.
Even bordain was saying,
ah,
sometimes I think about it,
I think about the weather and I know
there's a lot of good things about La
and a lot of Nice places.
I lived here for the better part of
eight years in my early twenties and
stuff.
And it's a,
you know,
I mean it makes you soft.
I mean like,
cause it,
yeah,
I think just like with the weather and
things like that.
And it's also like,
yeah,
the leisurely kind of like kind of
thing.
Like there's not a lot of drinking.
It's a lot more smoking weed just
because like everyone has to drive,
you know,
so nobody like,
so everyone just like,
it went by so fast because there's no
seasons,
it's all the same.
So like I blinked and it was like,
wait,
I've been living here for five years
because I'm from New York.
It's like we have,
we have our winter winter's long.
It's one of the major cities like where
you have a hundred degree weather shift
in one year it can be a hundred degrees
and later that you can be zero degrees.
That's true.
That's interesting.
It's kind of like,
it's kind of a harsh kind of climate a
little bit and the summers they're like
suck cause it's just the humidity.
It just sticks to you and it's smelly.
Look at me,
I'm not a huge fan of New York in the
summer.
It gets very pissed like,
yes,
yes you can.
You can just,
it sticks to you at six year hair like
him.
He never lived in the city though.
I might've missed my shot because you
know,
now I'm married and kids and the whole
deal and I'm so sorry.
Kind of stand up comedian.
It's a lot of the,
the the only thing that we could
possibly make me live there is that like
I could do stand up there very easily.
Yeah.
You know,
it was a lot of,
a lot of like,
yeah,
well I think the island of Manhattan
only has like six of them.
Technically.
I think it's like five or six.
Uh,
comedy clubs get nick.
It was five or six.
Yeah.
There's gotta be more than that.
I don't know.
Like it's,
cause I have a buddy who was,
the seller has to clubs.
There's danger fields.
There's Caroline's,
there's a Eastville comedy club.
This is God.
My buddy opened up one in like 2010
we're already at seven.
Well he opened up one like in about like
2010 or some like that.
And he was talking about,
he goes,
actually there's not a ton you already
said.
Yeah,
yeah,
I saw that.
That's what I mean.
He was actually,
you said like,
yeah,
he goes,
when I opened up there was only like
six,
you know,
like he was like the seventh one or
something like that.
Because it's surprising,
at least on the island of Manhattan
itself,
there's not as many comedy clubs as you
think.
Do you know,
even though it's a mecca turn of the
century night,
the 19th to the 18th to the 19th to the
20th century,
there was a thousand or close to a
thousand billiard halls.
Oh,
Manhattan.
Oh Geez.
Yeah,
yeah.
No,
no.
That's what men did before video games
and pretty much,
and that's like when men didn't want to
have families,
they match bachelor life.
Would they would live in these pool hall
to play billiards,
Gamble and as Smoky Smoky Pool Hall?
No,
there's,
I spent a lot of pool back to the love.
It's voice.
Uh,
yeah.
There's actually not a lot of bill your
clubs there anymore.
I mean,
and I'm saying they do exist but like
getting,
you know,
there's only like a hint like smattering
of them to the bowling alley.
It's like there's only a few bowling
alley.
That's right.
Yeah.
I think even like bowlmor like moved,
like kind of thing like into knew that
that was the trendy spot.
There's going to be like croquet,
bygone play,
some badminton.
Yeah.
Forgotten era games.
Let's play some squash.
But do you,
do you,
are you enjoying it out here now?
Yeah,
I mean,
I have a good life out of here.
Like I have like a really pretty little
family.
You know,
they've got a pretty girl,
pretty dog,
pretty cat and all that stuff and
everything's cool.
Yeah.
We're going to move,
we're going to like,
you were doing the house thing and all
that kind of style.
Are you going to get a house?
Well,
she,
well she is and I'm,
I'm just gonna,
I'm just gonna hit you right.
And I miss,
yeah.
More and more my ship in or did you just
run into,
it's,
it's on her,
like she was already,
she was already looking and so like,
yeah.
So I think she's an escrow like right
now,
essentially.
It just started like today,
but if it goes south,
she could just fucking boot you out.
Yep.
Just look looking to do it.
But I get my stuff at my place in New
York too.
I bought,
I bought like in like the 90s smart.
I'm doing okay.
You know?
Yeah.
But a proper loft.
Like I said,
I big syndrome,
I have the movie big and I'm like,
that's what I want.
So like elevator opens up to like a big
room and looking at it yet,
like I've,
I've,
uh,
I have more mannequins than like,
you would think.
Like we used to have an American apparel
downstairs and I was walking like out
one day and there was just a pilot
mannequin parts and I was like,
oh my God,
look,
God,
I forget the,
it's like an insight.
Then I told,
uh,
I told my super,
or like,
you know,
cause uh,
it's in the same kind of building
complex.
I said,
listen to everybody to get rid of like
any mannequin things.
Like tell him to come to me first.
What the fuck do you do these math?
They closed down and like,
yeah,
like I got like,
I have so many mannequins.
It's ridiculous.
Just these mannequin parts.
I have no idea what to do with them
either.
I have no,
I give them away.
Like it's like presence.
Like here's a leg,
you know what you're talking about.
All the different little cars that you
bought a bunch of.
Again,
every time I go to the pharmacy you have
to buy a toy car.
And now it's like,
I try not to double up on things.
So it's like only one ambulance.
Only one fire truck.
Only one corvette.
Yeah,
no.
And it's like now it's getting
ridiculous,
but I,
for some reason I call,
I'm like,
I hoard things and I collect things
like,
you know,
and at the same time I'm like,
I'll figure out what this is for kind of
thing.
Like,
you know,
I'll do something with those mannequins
at some point.
Somebody like those are going to pay
off.
I swear.
That's the kind of Shit that drives
women graze late,
ladies and gentlemen.
I am going to say invest in mannequins.
It's a growth industry.
It's,
it's,
there's this,
there's a high ceiling on mannequins.
I'm telling you kids,
I think that's a freedom thing when you
do whatever you want.
So you're like,
fuck it,
I'm just going to buy a mannequin.
Yeah.
So yeah.
And then when they closed down it was
like,
yeah,
I've got like 20 mannequins.
Do you get them for free or did you have
to buy them?
No.
So they were gonna like sell them and it
was something like there was like,
oh we have a like 16 of them.
Uh,
well some to you for $500 and I said
listen,
I said I could do that or I could pay
you,
you know,
or I can give you $40 I can give you
$200 for them and then give you $200
because the place is closing down the
store gets the $200 but then it's
another 200 in your pocket kind of
thing.
Cause cause the store is closing down
anyway.
Well cause because they're not going to
look,
they don't have a job starting next
week.
So like they really
don't care.
So look,
yeah.
So I got him for cheaper look just by
pretty much bribing.
The dude had offered him a drawing.
I know there's a little sketch market
so,
well listen man it was great meeting.
You need to.
I had to do this.
This is really fun.
There's a lot of fun and you're,
you're,
you're an interesting guy,
man.
You're,
you're very healthy for a guy who's
gotten through what you've gotten
through.
It wasn't,
like I said,
it wasn't too traumatic.
I'm going to,
you did it.
I did it one more time.
Your website for people bunny ears.com
and the podcast.
It's a bunny ears pod.
Uh,
it's,
uh,
you can get it again anywhere.
Podcasts are done,
you know,
so like,
whatever the,
whatever,
all those things,
they're listening to this.
They know where to get a block.
Yeah.
My,
my,
my podcasting partner.
It takes care of that.
Yeah.
That's,
you know,
like go check out our website,
go check out our facebook,
Yada,
and say hi to you at the human fest.
People,
people that believe in Britain.
Berlin.
I'm going to beautiful artifacts,
man.
Thanks.
Dot My friend.